ladies and gentlemen
donald trump has unleashed a new threat
to american democracy
so saith cnn why because donald trump
gave another speech
well he gave his first speech since
leaving office at cpac
he ragged on the democrats he ragged on
the rhinos the republican name only
hinted at a potential 2024 run and
talked about voter fraud and all that
stuff again and cnn is acting like it's
the apocalypse
but that's not even my favorite article
it's good right it's funny to read this
this just apocalyptic donald trump
his his deadly violence insurrection and
all this other
unhinged nonsense but vox also put an
article
talking it's a poll survey of republican
voters showing that
the republicans back trump like almost
everything he says they back what he's
saying
so when you see trump give this speech
it's not just
trump unleashing a threat of democracy
it's trump speaking to the voters
who agree with everything he's saying of
course
the media is now acting like it's the
apocalypse so we got a bunch of news
today we got that we got cuomo is
apparently admitting he's getting me to
now
three times they're really trying to get
rid of cuomo i guess
and then we have probably the most
important story in the world trending on
twitter is
whimxen you heard me right it's
w-o-m-x-n
and it's creating a backlash because
apparently the left is angry
that twitch the streaming service used
this word to try and be inclusive but
now they're saying it's actually
exclusive like uninclusive whatever the
word is
because it's creating a new word that's
like not
for regular women i don't it's it's dumb
no matter what you do you're gonna
offend them so we'll talk about that too
we have a fun guest tonight we got
cassandra fairbanks hey thank you for
having me
introduce yourself i am cassandra
fairbanks i write for gateway pundit
i yeah trouble on twitter
you start trouble on twitter i start
trouble on twitter
my favorite hobby there you go pretty
offensive
yeah all right good intro we got you
nice chilling hey everybody
uh this is for all the wimson out there
i'm gonna i'm gonna mix it i'm gonna
call him winston
i like professor xavier yeah yeah maybe
whimsical okay
oh man i got a lot to learn i'm glad i'm
here
teach me yes we're here for it and of
course i'm here in the corner pushing
buttons that's correct with my good pal
cassandra and my
and my dudes over here ladies and
gentlemen before we start reading all
this very very
important news check out
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can get
access to
biotrust ageless multi-collagen 51
off this stuff is awesome as most of you
know i am a skateboarder i
routinely engage in skateboarding
activities and i'm also a very old man
who's going to turn 35 in about one week
so uh i got to take this stuff seriously
and and i'm just going to i'm just going
to point something out i wonder if
they're going to get mad at me for this
they give me a script right to promote
them now i legit think biotrust is
awesome ian actually just puts them in
his coffee
it's so good it's good stuff and you
know if if you're somebody who's very
physically active and you want to take
care of your joints and your bones
and your skin you definitely want this
stuff they sent me this script though
and in it it says
it says uh supplementing collagen will
improve improve your
skin's elasticity making it smoother
more plump
and more youthful looking and i'm like
that's true
i'm just not entirely sure how many guys
are looking for that
in a product like i don't know you guys
watching you're probably like i wanna
have strong bones and be able to like
punch a bear you know but hey if you
want to be youthful looking and have
plump skin
i mean definitely you know collagen does
it for you so stronger
bones and life we've got some important
uh things to add to this so you get a 60
60 day money back guarantee the healthy
aging support of collagen in its ideal
form comes in this one right here
five key types of collagen you need from
four different sources
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility to
support maximum benefits
for every order today they will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org that's actually really
awesome
today biotrust has provided over 4.4
million meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 5
million meals this year
it is non-gmo and free of artificial
flavors preservatives sweeteners
free of gluten antibiotics and rbgh and
rbst
no odor or taste unlike bone broth and
other collagen supplements there is no
clumping
unlike other collagen supplements free
shipping on every order
free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust's team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order that seems like
way too good of a deal to be equally
honest
free new e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order i mean i
gotta be honest that actually sounds
really amazing
so look i i mean it i skate all the time
and i my elbows all messed up i got
swelled but that's what it's called you
got a swell but
it was so funny when you said that swell
bow it's when you hit your elbow and
then it swells up
so i legit i put this on my smoothies
and it's really good it's like
makes it strangely like thick and
delicious so again
go to strongerbonesandlife.com 51
percent off and serious thank you to
biotrust for sponsoring the show
let's uh oh and don't forget go to
timcast.com become a member we'll have
some more exclusive members only posts
there
and we greatly appreciate it but let's
read this first story from cnn
trump unleashes new threat to american
democracy
i think this should actually be titled
something like cnn has trump derangement
syndrome and they are unhinged
trump trump basically just said the
things he always says
there i got to be honest the headline
should actually be we're lying to scare
people
the president said the same thing he
said last month that's that i mean look
he gave a speech
i guess you know cassandra you liked it
i loved it i thought it was fun
but it wasn't like he was just like
bringing back a lot of the same talking
points
it sounded like usual campaign trump
right and
i personally love that but it wasn't
anything
outrageous it wasn't different it wasn't
anything he hasn't said before
let me let me read some of this donald
trump has
no remorse about the deadly violence he
incited with his lies
about a stolen election in his uprising
against the us congress like wow
definitively donald trump did this and
it's okay
this much was clear when the
ex-president put the republican party on
notice
sunday that he intends to use his hold
on its grassroots to try and suppress
the vote heading into the presidential
election
in 2024 what does that mean in which he
hinted he might run
how is he suppressing the vote if he
doesn't run no one's going to vote for
the republicans i mean there will be
some people voting republican but
this is just absolutely hilarious
they going to mention that he rags in
the supreme court and they say you know
leave
last seen leaving washington in disgrace
the ex-president self regarding wander
through old political fights
emphasized his obsession with revenge
at a time when the attention on the
majority of the nation not in his camp
is concentrating on more immediate
concerns
the distribute uh distribution of a
third coveted vaccine yeah yeah yeah
okay we get it
it's just the most bombastic language
about one thing they're saying that most
people are focusing on the vaccine
the white house had a press conference
at the exact same time as trump's speech
about a new vaccine and literally nobody
watched it
why would you nobody watched it
everybody was watching trump's speech
like they're they're so like detached
from reality even people who hate trump
are addicted to them yeah
and so everyone all eyes were on that
someone pointed out there was like a
meme going around of of like the white
house press briefing or whatever on
covet or something i don't even know
what it was because i didn't know what
was happening and it didn't even break a
million views
and then trump's speech had like three
hundred
3.5 million views yeah like in like an
hour
trump had a million people watching at
one time
it was like 900 000 people were watching
him give a speech some ridiculous number
yeah dude so so check this out let me
let me let me pull
up the uh the unhinge let's just i'm
just going to read the headline
vox.com writes the republican revolt
against
democracy explained in 13 charts
the trump years revealed a dark truth
the republican
party is no longer committed to
democracy these charts tell the story
you know when we get media like cnn
saying this crazy stuff there's no
effort
at all to try and like calm people down
calm down
he's just speaking at a republican
convention he's just smack talking
it's it's political rhetoric just chill
out no they're like this is the end
he is unleashing a new threat and
republicans of abandoned democracy like
do they want fighting and violence
yes it's good for raiders that's great
oh yeah their clicks have to be way down
right now there's like no busy man
cnn's ratings went down 40 to the week
after joe biden came in office wow
jeez yeah so they're bleeding money i i
guess jim acosta got replaced
jeff zucker's planning on leaving like
cnn's so yeah they're definitely like
all i keep thinking is this is the kind
of stuff that i would like to see
written about a president that
authorized the bombing of syria
and blaming an iraqi militia that may or
may not have
been or not was it iraqi iranian militia
yeah like like
the new york times is like
iranian-backed militias and then in the
article we don't know if that's true
you want to talk about a threat to
democracy like that that should be what
the focus of this vitriol is but instead
it's
it's trump's you know it's bombing with
diversity though
yeah well then you can go to sleep it's
like all these democrats
tweeting like isn't it great having
military action under biden we can all
rest easy why
what's the difference a bombing's a
bombing this is what turned me off of
the left originally
um i was protesting more under bush
i was a leftist until six years ago
i protested like crazy um during bush
and then under obama everybody
disappeared except for like
a few code pink people and stuff
everybody was like
went back to sleep didn't care and i was
watching and he was droning everyone and
i was like hey guys
are we still anti-war what's going on
you're not a racist are you you would
criticize obama
yeah i i don't want to bomb little brown
kids in foreign nations
because obama is actually more brown
it's not racist when he bombs them
because they have color like they have
they have white privilege it makes sense
colorism is a thing they start talking
what is it like the lighter your skin
apparently you get like certain
privileges i guess
so it's like i guess the idea was that
when they had when they started talking
about white privilege
the problem was that asians typically
have like higher incomes and education
so they're like well
i mean it's well if you're closer to
white then you have privilege too so
that
that that explains it it doesn't but for
sure let me pull up these charts because
this is this is crazy stuff look at it
so vox.com
first today's republicans really hate
democrats
and democracy one trump supporters have
embraced
anti-democratic ideas this is not true
it's just false framing
but let me show you what they say maga
supporters who
support trump's election fraud claims
nearly 100 percent
of trump supporters support his claims
on fraud distrust the election results
same percentage nearly 100 percent
believe voting shouldn't be easier
about 90 percent uh distrust 2020
congressional election results
about 80 percent want a third term for
trump only about 70 percent want a third
term for trump
but i'll tell you not trusting the
election system does not mean you oppose
democracy or democratic ideas it means
you think one thing
was wrong well when i was on the left we
didn't trust the election results either
i mean they rigged it against bernie i
still believe that
um i never believed election results i
remember
even under like bush i was like there's
no way this guy got a second term
i don't trust this like i've never i've
always thought elections were rigged
and i always think of the mark twain
quote where he's like if you know voting
actually mattered they wouldn't let you
do it it would be illegal
yeah and so i i mean i've always thought
that i i
love how so when that when that shadow
campaign article came out from time
magazine
i posted something like you know they
they said they started this campaign
against
not against anybody they started a
campaign to fortify the election in fall
of 2019
and i'm like so these high-profile
democrats started
colluding conspiring as per time
magazine's own words
in fall during the democratic primaries
and you do not realize that was like
against bernie too
yeah the funny thing is i'll point that
out and then i get a wave of these
lefties on twitter
saying things like uh you know the far
right is only pretending to support
bernie sanders or whatever and i'm like
i'm supporting i'm i'm pointing out that
you're getting ripped off no why would
you do that for bernie
or for uh biden and kamala in the
primaries yeah
well at first until the the the you know
buddha judge and whoever else
all dropped at the exact same time smear
campaigns against tulsi and bernie
and i mean i didn't see any like biden
stickers anywhere i saw bernie stuff
everywhere i saw tulsi stuff
and they just went full force fortifying
it
you know yeah
check this out so i say number two
republicans are embracing violence now
this one's actually interesting
there's a question this is from american
perspective survey january 2021
if elected leaders won't protect america
the people must act
even if that means violence 39
of republicans agree 17
of democrats agree the interesting thing
is i bet if you were to add
progressives to democrats because i
doubt it's the same thing
you ask like an anti-foreign black lives
matter person or a democrat they're
saying no
right screw the democrats so they're not
in this poll probably
i'm just speculating i bet it would be
like 75 percent
you add all those people and they're all
going to say of course oh yeah of course
it's crazy because thomas jefferson said
the same thing
i don't necessarily agree with it i
don't think we need to take it there but
what was it the blood of patriots
liberty yeah yeah refreshed with the
blood of patriot brutal
letter there's a lot longer than that
but he has this like one line at the
bottom where he says you know what to
say from time to time
the tree of liberty must be what does he
say watered uh-huh
the blood
[Laughter]
i love thomas jefferson i do too oh dude
i am offended he didn't know he's
amazing i've got a collection of tommy
jefferson coins
like a special little thing he's a
musician no thomas jefferson is not
antifa was just joking
anti-government violence he was
anti-fascist i'm sure that's technically
funny i think i don't know much about
him
yeah but like the problem is antifa is a
brand that has nothing to do with
opposing fashion that's a good point
it's like communists complaining about
fascists but they're just as bad because
they they're only slightly different you
know it's like two murderers and one
guy's like yeah but i use a gun and he
uses a
rifle i'm interested about this this
poll that you that you talked about
where
37 percent of republicans how many
people did they pull who were they
polling
what they didn't say the question was
america must be product
protected even with violence is that
what they said if elected leaders won't
protect america the people must act
even if that means violence what i don't
see that question should be a hundred
percent of people agreeing
yeah if you're not going to protect
america then yeah of course the
americans
like that well you see how they're
framing it though yeah that's really if
leaders won't protect america what is
that if like china lands on the shores
of
right san diego we just say oh they're
not doing anything i might
just go and run i mean i don't think
that means
like that they want to go do violence
you know
for political defenses fairly like that
question is would you protect america
and
everybody should say yes to that i think
that they worded that a little bit
it's weird it's a gotcha yeah let me let
me what they write they say the ultimate
expression of anti-democratic politics
is resorting to violence more than twice
as many republicans as democrats nearly
two and five republicans
said in a january poll that force could
be justified against their opponents so
i guess it's
against their opponents it would be easy
to dismiss this kind of finding as
meaningless
were it not for the january 6 attack on
capitol hill i'm sorry these people are
so duplicitous
we had a year of riots from antifa we
had 19
dead people plus peripheral you know i
think it's another
12 or 13 in the periphery that were
killed during these riots and stuff like
that
we had in the chas the armed guards
unloading
for 10 minutes hundreds of rounds into
an suv killing two teenagers
and they never talk about it because
they are duplicitous duplicitous
manipulative liars antifa attacked a
federal building two nights ago in
portland nobody talks about that
yeah what happened um they attacked what
was it the u.s
customs building i believe they started
vandalizing it spray painting it
people in in portland actually were
going out in the streets and yelling at
him
it was pretty interesting really yeah
but nobody talked about it
that was an attack on a federal building
that's horrible but it happened that
night
so it's not that surprising i forgot
about that yeah
i i'm you know i think portland i
i totally support antifun portland yeah
100 you know why they deserve it well
they voted for it
yeah but here's the problem those people
are going to destroy that city
they're going to get scared because it's
going to get violent it's going to get
unsafe and then they're going to flee to
the red areas that are safe
and then they're going to vote for the
same crap that got him into that mess
so they're fleeing to texas they're
going to destroy texas
they're you know the the problem is that
once they destroy it
they're going to come and destroy our
places too if they had just stayed there
and we had a big wall around it and we
were like do your thing i'd be like okay
cool
yeah wipe each other out i don't care
but
that's not what's gonna happen they're
gonna flee and they're gonna flee to red
areas because they're safe
and then they're gonna vote for the same
policies that got him into the mess in
portland and you're saying they voted
for the governor that is willing to
tolerate
the street violence well all of their
officials they're
local officials city council citizens
yes yeah
geez those people are crazy and then you
see them fleeing to texas and you
you know they're all fleeing to red
areas because those are the safe ones
and it's like
are you guys thinking about why those
are the safe areas they never do
is it guns it might be guns it might be
guns might be
yeah there's a ton of videos from when
antifa tried going into like some red
areas
and they just got stomped and armed
society is a polite society yeah
i think they're saying in l.a they
wouldn't go down on the crunch of
boulevard
oh they know where they can't go there's
other people have guns
that's really it so even if it's in a
city that banned guns they won't go
anywhere near that stuff
yeah but the way i see it with portland
is
all of these people voted for it and now
i'm supposed to feel bad for them
i hear what you're saying we'll have to
be prepared for that when they start you
know trying to come in
and there's a funny thing i was i was at
a gun shop and this guy was telling me
he's like oh yeah all the liberals are
starting to move into the red areas we
can tell
because they'll be complaining about
like my neighbor's trash or something or
like
the the neighbor you know put something
on their lawn and we all look at them
like so
my local facebook group there's a thread
with like hundreds of people involved
and they're all like
we need to start telling people from
massachusetts in new york and dc
how bad it is here yeah we have monsters
and our frogs bite and we play banjo all
night
it was really funny and everybody was
just like you know we would normally
would want peop
want people to move here we want to be
inclusive we're nice people
but they're going to ruin our our
community yeah
what if you couldn't vote in an area
that you moved to for like three years
or something
i say this all the time on twitter and
people attack me and say that i'm
anti-democracy but i i honestly believe
that you shouldn't be able to run for
office especially if you haven't lived
somewhere for a while
and i i think that you should have less
say in local politics if you just moved
in
i agree oh yeah absolutely i think that
people who have established roots
should have a little bit more say on
like local politics
think about like mitt romney bouncing
around the country because he's rich he
owns property in a bunch of different
places
and then he's like i'm gonna run for
office as a you know for
for the you know senate in utah yeah
just because i'll sign up his paper
saying i live here now it goes even in
local politics you have people who are
who don't even live in the community
running for the school board and stuff
we have people running
school boards in red areas that are from
blue areas and have
completely different politics in the
local community and it's not well
not right the problem with the system is
that the changes
you need to secure the system take
longer than the exploits to destroy them
right so you'll get someone from a blue
area thinking
i'm going to go and teach all these
redneck kids how to be you know
anti-racist
and the parents don't realize these
people are coming in right and then by
the time they're like we got to change
this like congratulations in five years
you might actually change the system
and by then your kids are going to be 17
and they're going to be totally
indoctrinated with this stuff
yep there you go so here's another
interesting one from the vox article
they say
republicans see democrats as something
worse than mere rivals
republicans who consider democrats as
enemies 57 percent
political opposition 43 percent and
democrats who consider republicans as
enemies is 41 percent
and political opposition 59 percent i
don't believe it no i don't believe it
either that flies in the face of the
echelon insights
where they asked it was it was it's a
company they asked democrats what their
you know
how how concerned they are with various
things the most threatening thing to the
democrats was
trump supporters the second biggest
concern i should say biggest concern
white nationalism white supremacy blah
blah blah
for the republicans it was like illegal
immigration and taxation so for them to
come out with this poll
i question the way they're phrasing you
know these questions
like the other protecting america would
you protect america with violence
i'm surprised every republican didn't
say of course yeah i'm surprised
democrats didn't say yes too
you should protect yourself i'm not you
have to protect your home i'm not
surprised
and they're not saying like protect it
from other americans the question is
just would you protect your home
of course you would protect your home
but it's that question is insane
right it's like they're they're assuming
that the the threat to america that the
government's not stopping is like a vote
a voter fraud case or something and like
that they yeah they're thinking
but if they're talking about actual
invasion and the in a la presidential
ineptitude then the answer is yes 100 of
the time or your country's
in our constitution like that's that's
amer an american value
look if we remain on this path with this
being the ideology that if you say
something like that you're considered
far right or bad
well this country's gonna fall apart
that's it it's over yeah violence is a
weird conversation
you know especially no just in general i
mean you do it of course online of
course in public because you got to be
careful about how you phrase violence
and frame violence and talking about
violence but like it was the
the crux of our country's formation we
had to violently overthrow our our
political rivals our
the the british monarch and over like 20
years it wasn't people don't realize
this that it took like 20 years
yeah yeah there were a bunch of things
that happened like the the
was it the boston massacre as i was am i
thinking the right one yeah that wasn't
like these things happened years apart
from each other
so we we view this history as entirely
condensed because it's like the key
talking points but imagine like
when we look back on history in 100
years or 50 years
they're going to mention everything that
happened in the past four years in rapid
succession and people will think it like
happened one after another when it was
like
the battle for berkeley happened what
was that now two and a half years ago or
something yeah
yeah that was a while ago yeah two and a
half years ago yeah it was like
it was i think it was like march of 20
no it was almost wasn't it
it's like march or april of 2018. was it
2017. i don't remember
2017. no no oh yeah i think it's a long
time
it was 2017. it might have been yeah
yeah cause like after i got back from
sweden
yeah wow what was that uh is when this
huge battle happened between anti-fun
like right-wing groups in
in in berkeley and we saw the based
stick man
he's like finally 17 2017. yeah
wow holy moly so this was the uh
the rise of the based stickman they
called him and it was like all these
conservatives were getting just
absolutely clobbered for a year or two
without fighting back
and then one day they do this rally
everybody gets beat up and then i think
it was the second time this dude shows
up
with uh with goggles a mask a helmet a
shield
and a giant stick i think it was a
closet dowel you know like for hanging
out yeah
and he cracked it over this auntie foe
as a woman wasn't it
sure he cracked it and it shattered over
someone's head and they're like
but it's like i watched this stuff go on
for years in
in san jose i watched that guy get
smacked in the back of that with some
kind of bag i said it was a bag of rocks
and he's a regular guy he was walking on
the street and he was like yeah capital
over
an election god is speaking to us
through the internet
no some site just auto loaded anyway so
i saw this guy he's got a sign and he's
yelling trump trump trump
some dude runs up behind him and smack
it has a bag and whacks them with it
and then it's in there covered in blood
like confused as to what happened that
was i think i think that was in 2015 i'm
not sure it might have been 2016.
i'm not sure it's all it's all been ours
together can't believe how long it's
been
yeah and so far so so we see the battle
for berkeley it's like finally some
right
right-wing individual started saying
enough and fighting back
and then all of a sudden i remember i
was there and i saw proud boys there
like three proud boys
and i was like what are the proud boys
doing here what is this who are these
guys like why are they here why are they
fighting
like they're getting arrested now what's
going on that was when things started to
really really heat up
that was years ago so it's crazy isn't
it imagine like 50 years they'll be like
the second american civil war
and then they'll be like in 2017 the
fight broke out in berkeley california
in 2020 donald trump did this you're
like whoa whoa whoa that was three years
later
yeah isn't that crazy that's the other
thing too that's kind of driving me
crazy it's like
how how long is it gonna keep going on
for it's getting boring it seems like it
started with the housing crisis i'm
trying to just be more like
observant from the outside it seems like
it started with the housing crisis when
it really started to get crazy and then
the drone strikes everything like like
obviously the september 11th
was when the everyone went on high alert
patriot act everyone was thinking
terrorists are all around me oh my gosh
and that kind of heightened the fear and
then but the the housing crisis probably
probably angered a lot of people and
then obama bailed out
those those mega corps inequality
occupy wall street and then at occupy
wall street you had this
bipartisan rage at the system and then
all of a sudden the leftists came in
with
critical race theory and so you know
woke activism and then it just made the
conservatives leave
and then honestly you also had people
like hannity fanning the flames
like his whole his whole thing was
ragging on the left this was the most
annoying thing to me about occupy wall
street
was that i knew a dude who went on
hannity's show and hannity started just
criticizing and ripping him you know
going after him and he just argued back
and they fought and i'm like
why would you do that why wouldn't you
be like sean
you are correct the people who are doing
awful things down there
are bad what do we do we don't want them
here this is a bad thing for us
we want to fight against the big banks
that are ripping people off and the
bailouts and all that system
what what would you advise us on instead
it was adversarial like you're our enemy
and we don't like you because you're fox
news
and that was a big component of it like
there's another guy who got a ton of
attention because he was interviewed by
griff jenkins of fox news
that's his name right griff i don't know
him i don't know this name am i getting
griff's name wrong
anyway and uh
they didn't use the didn't use the
interview and so someone else recorded
the interview i think it was from
um the village voice i'm not sure and it
went viral because he was like fox news
only does this that and this and you
won't tell what the people are actually
doing
and it was kind of true and then all
that really created out of it was
by like like mutual combat between
tribes
whereas it was originally a populist
uprising with conservatives libertarians
ron paul types
leftists within a week it devolved
completely into leftist critical race
theory
and then it just fell apart that was
kind of the cool thing about game stonks
is it was the right and the left nobody
was talking about politics
and it was a nice moment everybody's
like let's just screw over these hedge
funds yeah i could i could totally see
that and i could see the reflection of
occupy wall street in that because
people were like together like they
really want to stick it together
like if i had done this exactly
way better but it's hard to keep
together have you been following that
story like does it look like that's
going to continue
um well game stock has gamestop
stock has gone way up again
i think it was at like 113 again yes at
120 right now yeah
so i had held on to mine my diamond hand
yeah and i was like way down
and then i noticed it was going back up
the other day and i was like yes
all right yeah so you're talking about
it being down yeah 120.
that's great yeah so they're still
fighting i mean
what i mean aren't so for those who
don't remember the story it's like the
hedge funds were shorting gamestop
everybody bought in to basically strip
a ton of money from these hedge funds
who would be forced to buy ridiculous
amounts
but are they still like it's been like a
month now i mean i haven't really been
following it still but
i i do have game stop stocks so i've
been following it a little bit
um the guy who originally had bought
into the gamestop
stocks which i can't say my life
dependent on it i just call
it game stonks because it's easier now
that's awesome but uh
the guy who had originally bought in i
guess he bought more
like a week ago yeah he doubled his
vision yeah the
deep fn value or the kitty guy or
whatever rory and kitty yeah and so um
other people i guess started buying it
and it went back up it went up to like
150 at one point and then
i think yeah i think yeah the peak well
hold on this is well today
to date was 1 30. wow yeah wow
dang if we're going to seize control
it's going to be with through the
economy not through the
pilot yeah i've been buying all kinds of
stock now i had no
i had never bought stock never paid
attention to the stock market
and then i was like i support this i am
jumping in
i'm buying some game songs and so now
all of a sudden i own like a million
different kinds and they're all into it
it's
it's great what do you use to get your
stock um
well i was using robinhood but then they
kept limiting and so
right now i'm using a few different apps
but i admittedly still have robinhood
because it's easy
but i don't recommend them i am not a
fan um
but yeah i've been buying like six flags
and disney
yeah amc yeah the 52 week high is 483
for gamestop wow
whoa someone bought in when it was at 18
in january and then they sold out when
it hit 400. yeah
millionaires overnight i think the
economy is going to collapse to be
completely honest
because right now you have
a meme economy we don't have a communist
command economy we don't have a
socialist economy
it's barely a mixed economy at this
point because of the meme ism
it's not laissez faire capitalism i
guess technically it i guess you can
call it that
it's a meme economy where people make
money forget from getting attention on
twitter
they post something really dumb they
make something out of context they'll
insult somebody
try and get that meme to go viral and
then attach to it paypal me
but then you have dogecoin literally
just people throwing money into a meme
some people buy it they sell they made a
ton of money
and then with gamestop people are buying
this stock like crazy for what reason
it's a meme yeah it's a meme stock and
the crazy thing is like
people are becoming millionaires
overnight it was at like 40 bucks it
fell down from you know 400 or whatever
and then someone was like you know you
have to keep buying in and then the dude
the dude one of the shareholders of
gamestop posted an image
of a ice cream cone from mcdonald's and
then everyone went
nuts speculating that's what the ice
cream cone meant and then they all
started buying up more stock like crazy
rallying the price back up it's people
what's going on
i want right yes someone someone became
a millionaire
hypothetically i'm assuming it happened
i think there are a few but i mean like
imagine this you're sitting there with
like your eyes half closed just glazed
over
and you're like you know you know just
putting a you know couple hundred
thousand dollars into game stop and then
enter and then all of a sudden you hear
a ding and you look and there's an ice
cream cone on the screen you go oh
and then you'll get your account it's
like a million dollars like
all because some guy posted an ice cream
cone crazy the elon musk dogecoin meme
where he was holding up was a kanye was
holding up
someone else gene simmons yeah something
like that so i can't imagine an economy
can function that way
like if you think about how the economy
actually works with like
i we talked about this before i can't
remember who we had on the show we were
talking about this i mentioned
how does banking work like when when
when you spend money from one bank to
another
they don't physically give money to
anybody and then someone
commented it's just a ledger like
literally they just write down
he had 500 now he has zero and the other
guy says five zero and then 500
and that's just it literally they type
in a number on a computer press enter
and then the money's there
so you think about how how how absurd
that is
they can easily just type into a
keyboard you know type on a keyboard
press enter and then boom make trillions
of dollars
that's bad enough the federal reserve
and all this stuff add in all the money
they're printing over kovid
add in the petro dollar and and just the
general market instability with conflict
let alone the covet crisis
and then add in the system is supposed
to be if you do
work that provides value to the system
you get value back to buy things and you
know do stuff
now people just get money from nonsense
yeah like
like i mentioned i think the craziest
thing is that people go on twitter
and they'll say like ian is super lame
enter
and then they'll wait for some retweets
and then add to it dude if you really
like me ragging on ian then
paypal me and i'll make fun of him more
and there are literally accounts
dedicated just making fun of people
so stupid imagine getting rich from that
i guess
entertainment's interesting with mass
media the ability to like make a video
and then it go viral and you can make a
million dollars in ad revenues
relatively new i mean you back in the
day 600 years ago if you were a musician
you'd basically work for
for your dinner you know you'd travel
around and hopefully someone would pay
you to stay at the yeah they're in for
the night and that was your life but
then
mass media allowed you to make become
rich as an entertainer
replicating that music and then selling
one record a million times now all of a
sudden instead of performing one time
you perform a million times
at once and you're rich now that's what
this tweet this
tweet paypal stuff is too you know a
million people see that one tweet
i just figured it out i'm gonna start an
organization that issues
golden twitter birds gold
platinum and what what is it silver
silver no
there's no silver records either
palladium no like
you know you've got a gold record or a
platinum double a double platinum
twitter yeah so when your tweet goes
extra viral
and then you you'll get a little
platinum bird and everyone can knows
that's what you're famous for
could you imagine the future is is
depressing
well in addition all the things you're
saying about the people being able just
to type ledgers you know
the the petro dollar the inflation the
m1 money supply there's
there's crypto which is now also
completely disrupting the global
monetary system
and i'm i mean i don't know are you deep
in crypto right now um
not really i have some bitcoin i have
some doge but i am not
super doge i'm starting to get a scary
feeling that
the people in in control if there's any
such thing are just going to crash the
whole thing and then become super rich
on the crypto that they've
i mean that's kind of how it's always
gone to an extent
but i wonder if you know when it comes
to crypto trading
you've got people who are making money
day trading cryptocurrencies because
they're
not stable becoming rich off of just
like
it's it's kind of busted yeah you know
and then they'll build an ai that does
it for them
yeah they do they already have that
they've been there been programs for a
long time where you can just
this is crazy there was a program i
remember what it was but you'd tell it
make me money and then it would be like
okay and
it just like would start trading crypto
it was it was something to do we talked
about this before where like some some
crypto was worth
one satoshi the lowest position of the
the lowest
decimal point for a bitcoin so it could
literally
only double in value it was worth one
it could be worth two that's it it
doesn't get any smaller than that
so you buy a thousand and then as soon
as it hits two
you sell them all and you doubled your
money and so there's programs that would
just find
the out of the you know hundreds of
garbage coins
and just buy all of the ones that are
sitting at one and then as soon as they
jumped it would sell boom
and then they'd wait for it to go back
down and then buy again it's just
somebody's losing money on that did you
what maybe i don't know i don't know
somebody's well somebody's buying in it
too and that's going yeah but then
maybe they saw three did you know you
know how much money these women make on
only fans
no how much there was one woman who
posted over a hundred thousand dollars
per month
geez yeah only fans
and so it was like there's a thread i
tweeted about it one woman said
something like
why would you use only fans like when
i'm there at the club the dude hands me
the money and then i've got it right
there i'm not gonna pay a fee to some
app
and then some woman posted after like
something like this monthly
income and y'all thinking i'm going back
to the club and it showed the breakdown
of all the revenue and it was like a
hundred and eight thousand dollars in
one month
and she paid like a twenty thousand
dollar premium to only fans
so now now twitter's announcing they're
gonna do super subscribers
oh how's that work you uh okay
you you it's not impressive all my
offensive tweets right
the liberal journalists come after me
definitely i'm gonna i was i'm gonna put
most of my stuff
on the paywall because i don't want the
trolls
but then yeah when i say things that you
know piss people off it's like well you
got to pay to get pissed off
yeah it's going to be really interesting
how the super super it might actually
fix twitter
it might because now these people what
they like to do
is they like to go to my or you know
cassandra's twitter feed or just any
other high profile person
screen grab it and then instead of quote
tweeting it screen grab it so they can
rag on you and generate hate
and then what they'll do is they'll take
like a screenshot of a tweet from
cassandra
then they'll tweet imagine being this
dumb what a far right loony
and then all of these leftists will be
like haha so damn so dumb and then the
original person will add don't forget to
paypal me or subscribe to my patreon and
try and monetize it well there's two
possibilities
or not necessarily two possibilities but
there's two things that are going to
happen
people like that are not necessarily but
may
pay while that content because you'll
want to see what crazy cassandra said
you know can you believe she said this
and then it says pay five dollars to see
this image
and it's cassandra's tweet yeah isn't
that crazy yep
so maybe though if cassandra puts the
tweets behind a paywall they're not
gonna get it because they're not gonna
pay for it
so if the troll won't pay the five bucks
for the post
they don't got to post it to share it's
a real troll toll
a troll i love it i'm into it yeah
if you want to get into this boy's soul
you got to pay the troll toll
do you guys know that reference no what
is that
it's from it's always sunny they were
doing the uh
the play oh yeah charlie charlie wrote
and the demon
danny devito was supposed to say boy's
soul but he kept saying boys all
boys hole you want to get into this
boy's hole you got to pay the troll
tonight he's like no
what boys soul that's what i said i
gotta watch this show
that's a really old episode amazing
episode love it let's talk about the uh
the
latest uh uh social justice outrage
though gosh my friends
i give you the whimxion controversy one
of the greatest scandals of this or any
generation
and i imagine many of you is going to
turn this the podcast off you're like
this is stupid i don't care no hold on
hold on don't leave just yet
twitch which is a streaming service many
of you are probably familiar with it's
owned by amazon
it is ultra woke right so we had uh do
you know who destiny is cassandra
vaguely he's like a leftist streamer he
did
he streamed on twitch he was a partner
and he said kyle rittenhouse was clearly
self-defense
and he's and he's a leftist right and he
and we had him on the show and he was
like it is the clearest case of
self-defense he's being chased
you know and then someone shoots they
kicked him off the partner program for
saying it wow that's how lefty twitches
yeah so twitch puts out this tweet
march is wimmickson's history month i'm
not kidding
w-o-m-x-n wymixon
join us in celebrating and supporting
all the wmics and creating their own
worlds building their communities and
leading the way on twitch
and then the word whimxin started
trending and
i was actually surprised to find it was
actually the woke left that was upset
over this and there's a weird unity
forming between like
the anti-woke and the woke on this issue
i gotta show you this tweet
from count dankula he says
imagine being trans and fighting your
whole life to be considered a full woman
and they instead change it to whimxen to
point out that you are still
trans lmao that's a good point he then
said
leftist stop retweeting this calling me
based or calling it a redemption arc
when it's an opinion i've held for years
dankela then says stop acting like i
like trans people i only like trans
people when i'm horny
dankela is clearly joking i want to
stress
the point is people are acting like
dankula is saying
something new like defending trans
people but he's actually
defended them quite a bit the past and
he's pointing out
this new word whimxen which is like
going viral
twitter daily caller is an article okay
we'll read the daily caller
twitch gets dragged for declaring march
whimxion's history month oh they're not
gonna let me read it oh they will yeah
oh okay
wymixon so this this is a funny thing
that happened
a while ago where some like british
organization
said you know wimmickson's rights or
something and then it created this huge
fight between the left and the left
because the left hates the left i guess
where they were like the word wimixon is
exclusive it removes trans women because
if trans women are women you only need
to say women right
that was my first reaction when i saw
the video i was like how is
left doing this isn't the whole point to
not other these people
like now they're completely othering
them i saw it and i was just like
if i was a trans person i feel like i'd
be offended yes
and then they actually were so at least
good on them for
so someone someone someone emailed me
they said that the x
means trans and so that's why they do
falx with an axe
and they do whimx in oh really because
they're adding an x to everything
yeah i think i've not heard that that's
what someone said i guess it kind of
makes sense
and that's oh yeah like cross crossing
over interesting i guess what about
trans men are they mixin mxn
has that been the thing yet i don't it's
coming yeah i'm sure it is you just did
it there you go congratulations
and you're a bigot i have mixed feelings
about trans
the whole thing because i support people
i love people i want people to be happy
but when especially in sports like when
you see a trans
woman who was a man that transitioned
into a woman that is a male who
transitioned into a male woman
yeah just dominate other women in a
sport that it's
it's disturbing to me personally i get
disturbed because
they're much taller a lot of times their
bone mass is larger
um you'll see like these pictures of
like this large trans woman just like
muscling out these young these smaller
you know women
and um so people have said maybe we
should have a transports
and non-transports i think that's smart
well then that's the problem the same
problem of whmixon is you're creating a
new category
to separate people out this is an
impossible conversation
you know it's like no matter what side
you take they'll have to get mad at you
no matter what like there was one
prominent uh trans woman creator who got
cancelled for claiming there were only
two genders
and then it resulted it resulted in this
huge gen z versus millennial fight over
what it means to be trans because i
think as you can clearly see with like
twitch's wmixon
it's not the first time they used this
word like some corporations used this
word
everybody gets mad there was a really
funny uh venn diagram i saw earlier it's
a meme
and it's got like conservatives liberals
and leftists
and then it says like it says like
conservatives and leftists like guns
but you know liberals and conservatives
like capitalism
and then liberals and leftists hate
trump and then
for leftist and uh the the one thing
that all of them were united by
was when they all overlapped it said
hates leftists
so like even even the leftists hate
leftists they do
they absolutely do so i i it's a
why would you want to be in that space i
have no idea that's a rough one
but it's almost like a self-hatred i
don't know where it comes from exactly
well because i think there's
conservative conservatives and liberals
who are tribal and don't like each other
but i think leftists
tend to be not always there are some
i'll i'll i'll differentiate the
progressives from
the tribal leftists there are a lot of
progressives who are
great you know people like kalkalinsky
and crystal ball are good people
and then you have these weird leftists
who will just say whatever it is to
oppose anyone who's not a leftist
so they end up supporting really weird
nonsensical things like
25 000 armed national guard in dc with
razor wire fences
like why would it why would an
anti-fascist support this
because they're not really but they do
hate themselves that's why obama called
it a circular firing squad
the the the transports thing is a
difficult conversation i suppose
mostly because i'll tell you this i just
recently had a conversation with someone
and like i'm i'm i'm actually not in
agreement with most of the conservatives
on this stuff
like when it comes to uh pronouns and
things like that i tend to lean left a
lot of this stuff
but i was talking to someone and i said
with the equality act
which you guys know the quality act
passed in the house
it's where they're going to add gender
identity to the 1964 civil rights act
so my question was how do you protect
biological sex as a protected class
and gender identity at the same time you
can't
so but why do you think so because
you're taking away
women's spaces and female spaces
yeah and it's just i
personally don't see how it can co-exist
at all especially with sports
sports is like the big the big thing
where it's
really noticeable that this these things
collide
how are you going to protect little
girls who want to get scholarships and
these things that they've worked on
their whole life
when you know they're never going to win
against people who are bigger than them
have more testosterone than them
um i just so there was
uh there is an interesting point someone
brought up when i was
when i was arguing with someone about
this i was just saying arguing having a
conversation because i wasn't really
arguing with anybody
they said what about somebody who's
never gone through male puberty and
they're they've always been
either on puberty blockers or on
estrogen so they're
i mean i fully oppose putting on
children on puberty blockers
i mean like hardcore fully oppose this
but
i guess in that case it might be a
little bit different i know they're
doing testosterone tests
for uh at least professional sports so
stuff like that helps but
you see like i think it was
this like mediocre male runner beat the
fastest woman in the world yeah and it's
just like
how are your high school girls i have to
compete now i had a really interesting
conversation when i posted on
i was i have a bunch of lefty friends
and i posted on their facebook how do
you protect
biological sex and gender identity at
the same time and here
what i said was imagine this and i use
the the showers example
as it's it's it's the easiest example to
become honest
it is an easy argument because showers
are fairly visceral like we
want privacy in our showers so there's
there's basically a court precedent that
says
you are allowed to discriminate so long
as an equal space is provided for
the other sects so when there was there
was a lawsuit in california at some
university over women's programs
the judge ruled know their allowed
women's programs women's scholarships
because they have identical men's
scholarships
that's a really interesting court
precedent because that would you'd be
able to be like okay what about
segregation
well this week there was another court
case miss usa just won
they were sued by a trans woman who does
beauty pageants
and they because they refused to accept
anyone who wasn't a biological woman
and they just won and the court said
that it was because of freedom of
association
and then the lawyers for miss usa came
out and they were like you can have a
trans beauty pageant or you know
whatever you want to do
but this is for biological women and we
created a space
to showcase biological women yeah and so
you know there is another court case now
that's also setting a precedent i guess
that one yeah well so so here's the
point i was making if
if you say that it is unfair for
biological
women to be in the men's space
because men are biologically different
the army just did a new training program
because men and women are different
if you say that you know then you've got
title nine violation i guess what
originally happened was there was no
women's sports
and then a bunch of women sued saying
there should be a women's only division
because it's not fair so then we got
women's sports
so now they're saying okay it's not
discriminatory because there's a men's
division in women's division
there are a bunch of sports back in the
50s where they would not let women run
there's like a marathon and women
weren't allowed to be in it
today there is no rule in major league
sports
barring women from competing and so i'm
talking it's really interesting so
let me about the first point and we'll
get into this one i was saying
if you have two a female in a male
locker room
showers and then you decide that
somebody who's biologically male can now
use the female
side because of an identity you've
essentially taken away
a safe space for one marginalized
community for another marginalized
community because you believe one
community is more marginalized than the
other but you can't
quantify that there's no there's no
number where you can be like it's a
seven on the impression scale and a six
on the oppression scale
so you're basically just saying the law
says based on sex
and identity but then you you quite
literally have people arguing about
which one is more oppressed and more
deserving of that space
or not deserving of that space so in the
end what ends up happening is
i talked about this a long time ago i
got a lot of heat for it you don't end
up with
a man a male men's locker room in owen's
locker room and
you know trans people using whichever
one they want in the uk what ended up
happening was they just started building
unisex showers
and then due to general proximity having
nothing to do with trans people mind you
biological males started assaulting
biological females it wasn't like they
just started doing it it was because
proximity breeds opportunity i suppose
and there was a study that came out it
was in the fine i think it was in the
telegraph or the s i think it was the
sunday times i'm not sure
british paper saying they saw a huge
spike in
men males assaulting females because now
these showers and changing rooms
were in the same place and skeezy awful
dudes
had an opportunity now to do it so they
did so the question then is
how do you protect both the same time if
they're both in it in the in the civil
rights act
i don't know some people have pointed
out that we'll just have a functioning
society
where people know what the social rules
are you know like we don't violate
social norms so people will just get
along
but a really funny thing happened i
pointed out
that showers are an easy example but
what about the wnba
right if if if you can't discriminate on
the basis of sex or identity
couldn't someone go to the wnba and say
i should be allowed as a biological male
to compete in this and then the response
was
how come you you already can't
discriminate in the basis of sex so how
come no one has done that
that's a good point no guy is actually
apparently i mean maybe i'm not maybe
this is wrong
tried to get in there was a guy who sued
hooters
because they wouldn't hire him and then
a court ruled give him the job and then
he was like no i don't know
i don't want the job something
interesting happened
i pointed out that major league sports
don't
actually discriminate on the basis of
sex nba
nfl mlb women are allowed to play they
never have there's no rule
there's no rule and so i was told
repeatedly by these lefties that's not
true they won't allow women to play and
i said
that's incorrect and i sent him an
article from espn about women trying out
for the nfl
to be kickers and they had numerous
quotes from high
high profile uh coaches and
and scouts saying women just don't make
the cut
and so the response i got from the
leftist was i don't understand how is
that possible
maybe maybe a social stigma is making
the women not play as well
well has a woman ever won something like
the boston marathon
because that's not maybe gender
segregated
probably for women's yeah i don't think
that anyone
i can't think of a woman though who's
won the entire like who's actually been
first through the finish
i don't think so men are like four
minutes and 30 seconds i think
just blow women out of the water
relatives no it's like a time where 45
minutes or something
well so i wanna i wanna i wanna stress
this point the person
arguing with me said when i told them
women
are not barred from major league sports
he's like then why aren't they in
on the teams and then i very simply said
well
uh exposure to prenatal testosterone
results in more fast twitch muscles
which mean men have the ability to use
burst energy like jump higher
sprint faster and burn up energy much
more quickly they tend to have denser
bones double the collagen they tend to
be taller these are all tendencies not
absolutes
and then he said the response was could
there be a social stigma preventing the
women from actually scoring better
and i was like is that that's what they
think there could be
that that they've if a woman goes in the
locker room and gets raped
like that could be a disturbing thing
because they only have one locker room
but so i could see that women maybe
wouldn't want to put themselves in that
position
but they're also taking the most extreme
freaks of nature to play in the sport
and those tend to be men if not always
you know the strongest of the strong of
the humans are male
i don't know if that's always true it's
the highest top 1.01 percent of people
who are playing in any of these sports
and they're like always
male i mean for the most part aren't
they so the point i'm bringing up is
this leftist
genuinely believes that if you took the
average biological female and biological
male there is nothing stopping them from
competing equally
and that's to me it shows how culty
it's become like absolutely we should
have laws protecting marginalized groups
and all that stuff
we should have equal access to civil
rights people should be respected and
allowed to live freely
but come on if you're talking about
averages yeah i could see that but
we're talking about extremes for
professional sports you want the
extremes of human nature
right the point is this person genuinely
believed the average male and female
would compete on equal footing in
physical activities
do you know why that is i think i know
why it is theory
yes exactly it is the blank slate theory
um it's something that john jack
rousseau talked about
and he talked about how humans start out
being basically completely equal and
are completely shaped by the culture
they grow up in we know this is not true
like we can literally look at the
physical differences between males and
females you can look at the pelvis size
and shape
and you know the angle of the female
pelvis is completely different like
there's no i don't know person
i don't know i i we we have a we have
two women and two men in here oh yeah
and there's just they're completely
identical in every way you got to play
some bad guys completely yeah we are
completely done
you both have long hair i think
cassandra could kick further than me are
you sure you can both beat me at arm
wrestling yeah
for sure i'd be toast who's tall he's
taller yeah i think we're all about the
same size he's faster
i don't know i don't know maybe yeah
it's it's just well we're not freaks
we're not athletic
yeah we're just like do you guys hear
what bret hear what happened to brett
weinstein on clubhouse no
yeah you heard about some activists came
in and brett weinstein is an
evolutionary biologist right
and they were like you mean eugenicist
and he was like wait what no i'm like we
know what it means you're eugenicist
evolution is like they don't believe in
a revolution
i'm jewish i'm not sure if i'm white or
not it's kind of a weird issue
and they were like you're a spicy white
what
are you serious oh she got a quote i
died i was laughing so
they called him spicy white yes white
she was you're just a spicy white
[Laughter]
check this out check this out this is
the creepiest thing ever oh gosh yeah
so mentioning them calling brett
weinstein
they actually called him spicy white
yeah that is but if you want to hear it
i want to hear it
were you in the clubhouse no i saw a
clip of it on twitter
and i i started listening to it they
called brett weinstein this
yeah because he was explaining that like
he's not sure if he's technically white
or not because
jewish people are oppressed by europeans
and he's going on and on
and she goes you're just a spicy white
[Laughter]
i think these people are hilarious i
think they're anti-semites yep
i think you know we've long talked about
say like farrakhan
we know these people have almost
identical beliefs
to the the the white identitarians
you know that many of them are fascistic
many of them believe in
racial segregation now we have this from
the sacramento city
unified school district i am you your
ear your head's going to explode when
you hear this my friends
if you have any left like liberal
friends who don't believe you
send them this website and have them
read this
now you got to be careful because these
people in these tribes desperately want
to believe it
and i'll tell you what happened first
let me read this for you and i got to be
very careful because if any of this gets
taken out of context
as if i said it wow check it out they
write
and again this is a sacramento city
school district anti-racist classroom
racial affinity groups offer a structure
of inquiry
and can address many needs they support
us in exploring what has been
forbidden forgotten and unhealed
okay forbidden remember that word for
example in racial affinity groups
white people can discover together their
group identity
they can cultivate racial solidarity and
compassion
and support each other in sitting with
the discomfort confusion
and numbness that often accompany white
racial awakening this
i i what i don't know dude this is
this right i know right let's just be
honest hold on hold on
why is the school trying to tell these
these classrooms
to teach white people to find their
white racial identity to have a white
racial awakening
that doesn't sound like litigationists
kkk
it sounds like the clan wait hold on
hold on it gets better oh boy
this is so so i i post this on instagram
that last bit i highlighted
someone posted it on reddit and the
moderator was like this is a lie here's
the full context
they added this part they can also
discern white privilege and its impact
without the aid of
or dependence of people of color white
people who have formed racial affinity
groups report they recognize their
collective commonality and shared
history
as well as the impact that their
privileges had on other races
and on each racial affinity group member
okay
do you know what happens to white racial
groups
when they're only hold on hold on what
would you call it
what would you call it i love it when a
group of white people come together
to share their history and talk about
the impact the white race has had on the
world
and have a common and shared experience
as they awaken to the reality of their
race
what do you call that when those groups
get a clan meeting maybe uh-huh
racist yep i mean racist af
i don't know if it's discriminatory
unless they're keeping people out but
this is the school doing it so i i
i guess regardless of how you do it if
you're yeah racist
here's the best part they try and make
it seem like that last sentence
is somehow absolving them of what
they're saying
like white people formed you know
recognize their collective commonality
and shared history the impact of their
privilege
when you take a bunch of white people
who are aggrieved
who are being bullied or told that
they're wrong and bad and they feel bad
and then you put them in a group a bunch
of other white people the memes have
always been
the birth of the alt-right there's a
comic that shows a bunch of you know
different race people like stick figures
and they have like you know flags and
like rainbow flag
and they're yelling at a white guy get
out fu and so the white guy looks to the
other
on the other in the other direction and
he sees a bunch of white people and he
says
okay and so that was a meme that was
pointing out
all of this critical race theory stuff
is doing is telling white people that
the only place you'll feel comfortable
and safe is in white racial affinity
groups for the longest time i've been
warning
the goal of what the critical race
theory stuff is doing is making people
white supremacist
it's going to make them vote along
racial lines to benefit
white people and then the left says oh
they're talking about white privilege
white privilege
regular people don't know what that
means regular americans middle class
working americans who are right have no
idea what you're talking about
all they're going to hear is you're bad
go hang out with a bunch of white people
they will and then once you pass
identitarian law
they'll be like okay we're going to vote
for identitarianism when they say
they're going to share their history and
the impact their privilege has had
another races
do you think they'll be thinking of
themselves negatively or positively why
would they think of themselves
negatively why why why would a bunch of
white people get together and say
hey you know that bad stuff we did or
what if they got together and said look
at all the awesome stuff we invented
you'll get the proud boys i mean they're
not a white racial affinity group but
they'll say
the west is best look at the things we
created the western world made
everything great
why wouldn't you get that from a bunch
of you know white bros hanging out
high-fiving each other
they're telling all of these kids
they're indoctrinating kids
to have a white racial awakening and
when i tell people that's no different
from the clan or white supremacy they
say oh you're crazy we're the good guys
we're allowed to do it
well cornell university was uh
they um just announced a rock climbing
class campus reform actually got them to
change the description of the course
when they reached out for comment
but they had a rock climbing class that
was for everyone except
white people and so i mean they're
pushing for segregation they want
segregation
and i keep thinking about that comedian
that i know you're friends with who uh
ryan long yeah he had that video and
they're both like we want segregation oh
the wealth of the races
i'm just like you know what i'm fine
whatever
i keep thinking of the ira the british
and the uh
the irish and they were all white but
they had massive because of religion in
that case the catholics yeah
massive conflict murder and desecration
of each other
regardless of their skin color it was a
religious thing so like
saying that white people have a shared
history is insanity we humans have
fought each other for reasons
unbeknownst it's a little bit more than
that i mean the irish were basically
enslaved by the british for a really
long time
yeah they were like tribal religion
played a role but when i went to belfast
in northern ireland the what do they
call it the peace wall is that what it's
called
it's the craziest thing on one side it's
like
the the pro-northern ireland people are
saying that they're the true descendants
of israel
and on the other side there's paintings
defending palestine and i was asking
this local i was like one struggle thing
what is that
one struggle for palestine or whatever
the ira
people and then palestine there's like a
really famous big
giant the british oppression yeah the
britons are the ones that created israel
with the balfour declaration and
basically i think basically what this
dude told me was anything
that the republicans would say then the
you know the the
the other factions the opposition would
say the exact opposite
and so when you look at the peace wall
you can see like black lives matter on
the other side it's like donald trump
and just like what does any of that have
to do with ireland and irish politics
and this dude told me nothing it was
funny this this young guy who grew up
here he was like and he was a kid in the
90s with all like the bombings
everything going on
he was like they just hate each other
they hate each other and they want
reasons to hate each other
so no matter what the other side does
they do the opposite and justify their
hatred for the other side sounds
familiar that's why segregation
is bad it's why we want to be alike are
you an american i'm an american great
american good yeah i remember
probably eight months ago this when this
kind of this identitary stuff
start i tend to tear the identity stuff
started really getting habitat
yeah like i don't know if it was eight
months ago but i i started to have this
wave of feeling like oh you're gonna
you're gonna tell me to go away and not
accept me
fine like i wanted to like i almost gave
over the dark side of like fine i'll
just
go join some white and it's i'm not
playing that game well it's been brewing
for a long time though i mean even at
occupy wall street
they were like if you're a white man you
can't speak
like they used to say that all the time
they'd be like shut up white man
i loved it because they would tell me
that and then i go i'm mixed race and
they'll go oh i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
yeah i remember i would cover like
protests and stuff
and they would be like all the the white
people covering protests need to go to
the back and then the people of color go
to the front and i'm like well i'm sort
puerto rican can i go somewhere in the
middle
what do i do and they'd say no
yeah they would take your way this is
the i'll tell you i'll tell you exactly
why
uh i don't like any of this stuff so and
i bring this up too because
there's like uh i i think it's fair to
say it was more of a meme a couple years
ago temple's mixed race i don't really
say it all that often
but with this stuff coming up i have to
because i have to make it
explicitly clear to all the leftists
when they create their racial affinity
groups
can i just ask which one do i get to be
in because the answer is none of them
and i experienced this first hand at
occupy wall street when they created all
their little communities
different communities based on race and
when i was like so which one do i go to
they said fu that was it they're like we
don't care we don't like you
robin d'angelo uh apparently i was
talking to carl benjamin from the lotus
eaters podcast about
her book white fragility and he was like
she basically admits like they have no
answer to mixed-race people at all
so like why would i allow racial
segregationists to make me a
second-class citizen i'm never gonna i'm
never gonna stand for these people are
psychotic the only thing that unifies me
with everybody else is basically
america i'm an american i mean i'm a
human we're all humans
i'm down for that can we get like an
alien invasion or something so that we
unify like an independence day or
something
probably probably i mean maybe that's
what's happening
but it's going to be martians and earth
and terrans basically if we're not
careful
if we colonize mars interplanetary
conflict we got to be careful could you
imagine like elon musk moves to mars
and then in like a couple hundred years
it's all the descendants of musk
and they're like the tribe of muslims
it's like a militaristic
south african you strange people
the musk clan yep god don't they all
talk like this
we're coming to invade your planet like
robots south africa kind of like robots
i don't know how elon musk talks is that
how he talks
dude i'm i'm worried about the future i
don't i don't think that these groups
are going to go the way they think
they're going to go i think they are
going to come up with a bunch of white
supremacists because i think you're
right
i think they're just closeted white
supremacists much like rob and angelo i
think it's on purpose yeah i
always hope that people go ahead and say
yeah
being white is great because it it
really upsets me watching like i have a
child and so i see like cartoon network
commercials and stuff like that
and they're they're just constantly
being like if you're white you're bad if
you're white you're bad
and i think that's a horrible message to
give to any child
they can't control their skin color and
it it
bothers me on like a really deep level
that i'm seeing my like
my child watching this stuff where
they're saying that she's
evil like my daughter didn't participate
in slavery or
you know anything like that she doesn't
care what color somebody is
and they're targeting children with this
stuff constantly and the right doesn't
target children at all with any
political stuff because they believe
that children should be left out of it
and so we're they're playing on a
fighting field that we're not even
touching
and it scares me like i don't think that
children should be told to hate
themselves based on their skin no matter
what color they are
yeah and they're they're targeting all
these white children constantly
like you're white you're bad yeah white
you're bad but it's not gonna
it's not hated i think on the surface we
adults
see that and say oh no these kids are
gonna internalize and hate themselves
i don't think so i think kids rebel and
i think you you you put these kids in
white racial affinity groups
and then tell them how bad they are and
they're gonna be like nah
we're cool and then they're going to say
the opposite of what the adults say as
children do when they rebel
i mean i think i was reading about the
natural cycle of like youth and
rebellion
and the importance of it for human
civilization that
the the youth needs to challenge the
tradition of the old to make sure this
constantly some kind of societal change
lest the society grow stagnant and then
collapse so let's say
you have uh it's kind of like evolution
the slow
changes allow for an opportunity to
improve the greater
so the the youthful generation is always
challenging the older generation
and trying to change things make things
better and sometimes they things don't
change and sometimes they do
so you have a bunch of kids who are
constantly rebelling against the older
generation i think it was socrates i'm
not entirely sure
who complained about how the kids yes
was it socrates yeah i think so he was
like the kids don't listen to their
elders their
their friendships disrespectful they're
all yeah they're all reading books
or something like that it's really
really funny to read that because like
it's like wow humans never changed
but the problem is that their their
favorite youtubers are saying it their
favorite celebrities are saying it
and so it's different than like parents
and like stuffy old teachers saying it
they're seeing it from people that they
think are cool
but i still think what's going to happen
is it's going to breed a very large sect
of the alt-right
it's going to bree so so the way i put
it earlier is
you have 60 of this country that is
white let's say
a small percentage of them are woke
leftists who actually watch this stuff
because
like i think we all it's all fair it's
fair to recognize most
people don't know anything about this
including you know latinos who have no
idea what latinx means like 97 like what
i don't know what that means
so how many white people actually
understand the woke stuff probably not
that many
of those who do how many are on the left
so what you end up with like 10
of the people falling for this but then
what happens when
the other 10 percent who hate it
you know are also in these groups i'll
put this way
every single kid who hears this is not
necessarily going to just agree with it
you'll get some amount of disagreement
they are breeding white supremacists
kids who will say
no you're wrong i actually think it is
better or things like that
the other issue is that if they keep
doing this
and eventually regular working-class
americans who just happen to be white
feel threatened and aggrieved well then
they'll start voting based on race and
that's apparently what they want and
then guess what congratulations 60
of the country is not going to vote
based on a race how does your daughter
feel about it have you talked to her
i don't want to talk about my daughter
on here really but do you have deep
conversations about it with the kids um
we try and avoid that stuff in my house
i don't have cable so we don't actually
get the commercials except when i was on
vacation
um but i was watching it and i was like
holy crap they're talking about
impeachment on the disney channel what
yeah and it shocked me and i mean we
don't really watch that stuff we watch
like mr beast and crap at my house but
um yeah i don't know my daughter is
homeschooled so it's a whole different
ball game than what the kids who are
in public school and getting the black
lives matter curriculums are seeing
dude i was playing apex legends and i
saw some cool banner and i was like oh
that's pretty sweet so i just put
equipped it to my guy and it was this
fist
sticking up with a yellow background and
then another one of my friends was like
that's the black lives matter
thing dude and i was like what really i
didn't even know yeah like i'm kind of
in it and i didn't know like
there's a youtuber that's for kids and i
i was watching some of their videos
because my daughter likes to watch
roblox videos and i i
like to see what they're doing so i was
checking out this channel
and he's going on about how if you're
not attracted to trans people that
you're homophobic and i'm like this is
targeted towards kids who are like
seven it's a roblox channel and
i i was just astounded like you you have
to really
watch what your kids are watching now
it's it's terrifying
and the right isn't touching this this
field like the children
are being targeted by the left they're
paying big money they're going
commercials on disney
they're getting curriculums into schools
and the right
largely wants to keep kids out of
politics we don't want
you know and they want their kids in
these schools i i never understood
the absurdity of being like they're
inducting indoctrinating our kids in
these schools with their roke curriculum
i demand my kid be put back in school
yeah okay then shut up
put your kid in the school i don't care
homeschooling that's what well that that
that
you you get these these uh news stories
where like the teachers union guy in
california
is saying schools can't be reopened and
then sending his kid to a private school
uh-huh they're going to send your kids
to the wolves to the indoctrination
we'll call facilities because they're
not camps they're facilities you know
where your kids go to school and they
learn all this weird racial stuff and
they put your white kids in a white
affinity group so you can learn about
white history and shared culture
congratulations on that one and then
your kids are going to be in that and
they're going to send their kids to the
fancy normal schools
where your kids will be indoctrinated
and made to believe this crazy stuff
my friend sent me a video uh this week
of her son's class
um and she was teaching his teacher was
showing the class how to do the black
power salute these are five-year-olds
like these kids are being dipped in it
from like two years old yeah
like and that's right we'll never go
there because we want kids to be kids
right
and so it's bad and we're they're on a
whole different playing field than we
are
well tim is absolutely right yeah yep
they've been there actually fighting
like a serious
serious fight here and we're not and
we're gonna lose because of it and tim
is absolutely right about complaining
about not school
schools not being open like why would
you complain about that yeah
i haven't got that either right i'm like
wait no this is great yes
yes yeah where the
local community gets all their kids
together you hire one tutor yeah because
that'll feel
smart i live in best west virginia now
there's actually a bill making its way
through congress
in our state where they're gonna fund
children instead of institutions
a lot of states are doing that yeah i'm
so amped up
it went through the senate and congress
now i think it has to be signed by the
governor
i could be wrong how does it work but
it's great
so instead of the money because each you
know public school gets like 20 000
a year or something per student so
instead of that money automatically
going to the public schools
the parents will be able to choose
whether they want to spend that on home
school supplies on private school
on sending them to a charter school
or sending them to public school and
then they'll get that money and the
teachers unions really oppose it because
nobody's going to want to send their
kids to public school
but it's amazing and it's great and i am
really pushing for this to go through
and
i love my stage school choice school
choices yeah that was one of
trump's positions i'm in favor i'm
absolutely in favor of yeah it's a
little
a little disheartening that hey if
you're going to be a teacher you might
be out of a job
you know the age of of automation is
coming
and but get a job think about that if
you're 17 and you're going to school
maybe you don't want to become a teacher
dude school or be a better teacher so
that people want to send their kids to
yeah you can teach those pods
public school in chicago was like
torture there was maybe like one there
there were like a couple of good
teachers there was one really good
teacher i had for the most part
who i respect i'm actually friends with
on facebook the other teachers were
it's criminal it was child abuse the
things these teachers
there's one lady i won't say your name
absolutely despicable
old hagrid obese woman who would just
insult
and berate and just crap all over these
kids every day and i watched it
now for me you know i when i was like
nine my family started a business and so
i was very independent on my own
building computers having a job and
understanding what it meant to actually
be responsible
so hearing this this you know morbidly
obese nasty woman
rag and insult me was meaningless to me
because it just it doesn't affect me
i've got more important things to do
but i could see how it was affecting
these kids who are like 10 10 years old
seeing them cry
seeing them hate school and i was just
like i never took school seriously which
is why like
a year later when i was going to high
school i just stopped going to school
because i was like
is what a waste of time but so many kids
were just brutally abused by teachers of
the schools i've been to
and that's public schools and then and
we're supposed to just
blindly follow the teachers union
because union union good
sorry i don't care the only place that
most children see violence
is in public school wasn't it we
mentioned this before michael malus yeah
yeah so he brings that up a lot yeah
it's like one of the only place they'll
see violence
and he said they're basically prisons
yeah well chicago actually implemented
solitary confinement for their kids they
took like an 11 year old kid and threw
him into a solitary confinement room
full of padded walls
and then just left him there for like a
day and then he like crapped his pants
and then was crying and sitting in his
waist because he couldn't he was 11.
that was my child i'd be in prison right
now yeah probably would be too yeah
that's chicago but listen that's chicago
for poor people
the rich the rich people will advocate
for all of this stuff i mean i swear
we're headed towards
it's like every awful dystopian novel
all jammed in one like you guys remember
you see luke's shirt where he's got all
it's a venn diagram of all the dystopian
novels and it's like you are here in the
middle it's true man
you've got you've got an emerging
neo-feudalist system
where the ultra-rich advocate for laws
that make
life for the poor substantially worse
many poor people are too ignorant to
realize they're voting for their own
destruction the left agrees on this one
and and seemingly the right agrees with
the left both sides agree that poor
people are voting against their own
interests
the rich people know my kids never going
to go in that garbage school those
garbage teachers
so why should i care do it and then i'm
gonna send my kid to the to the moon or
whatever to elysium
where they're gonna get the pristine
beautiful uh education
and not have to worry about being put in
solitary confinement did speaking of
solitary confinement in children did you
guys see the story last night
i i was going to bed and i actually
jumped out of bed in a rage after i read
this
yes i think i know you but um up in
canada they were suggesting
that if your child got exposed to covid
in school that you put them in solid
in confinement by themselves for 14
days did you see the tweets yeah they
understand the parents
two parents came out and said that they
were doing it that they were in the
process of doing it
they got brainwashed into abusing their
own children
and overriding their maternal instincts
and
they ended up both deleting their
twitter accounts i believe because
people were like you are abusing your
child
like the united nations considers
solitary confinement for 15 days to be
tortured
and these moms are doing it to their
children because they are so scared of a
disease
or a virus that kill that is 99
for kids like 99.99 did you see the
tweets
so angry one of the tweets was the
their two tweets that went viral one was
the the hardest thing for me was hearing
my young son
crying locked and locked in the basement
or locked in the other room
one one of the tweets was i feel bad for
my son he keeps texting me mommy i'm
lonely
like wow i was in bed so tired i hadn't
slept the night before i was editing for
gateway all weekend
so i was like non-stop staring at the
screen and i was finally in bed and i
was like yeah i'm gonna crash
somebody sent it to me and i was like
yeah
i like lost i haven't i read so much
crazy stuff that i rarely get like
actually angry anymore but i read that
and i just
lost it i couldn't control myself i mean
i would eat an entire petri dish filled
with
literal coveted virus germs before i
would put my daughter into solitary
confinement that's crazy and i was just
like
how how did they get these moms to do
this
it's not just that the woman one of the
of the tweets she was like i have severe
asthma so we have to do this
and i think about you know how they're
saying we must sacrifice the young for
the old oh the old are vulnerable so
let's destroy the economy and shut
schools down
and i thought about when when did it go
from the all
the adults will sacrifice themselves for
the children so the children should
sacrifice themselves for the adults
well i'm the adult and i have asthma so
my child must be put in solitary
confinement
my mom has asthma she's hospitalized for
it all the time she's
in rough shape from it but she has
foster children and one of them got
exposed to covet at school
and my mom who was like in the highest
highest risk category for this
uh quarantined with him like and she
didn't get it
so i'm just like that's right that's not
like that's not even her child
technically and she put herself out
there to take care of him because it's
her responsibility it's her foster child
and these people like their actual own
children
i you know you know
we didn't get to the cuomo being me too
now by three women
but we'll go on about that all week but
we'll do that we'll do it in the bonus
segment because
it is a um it's an anniversary
and i want to talk about something of
which cassandra is like a foremost
expert on
waco right yes but first check this out
this is this is mind-blowing and i
wonder if you know this to cassandra
today or i'm sorry yesterday the atf
tweeted
we remember the fallen agents conway uh
conway lebloo special agent todd mckeon
special agent robert williams special
agent steve willis who made the ultimate
sacrifice
trying to execute a search warrant learn
more remember waco
february 28 1993. now
cassandra that tweet triggers you right
i am taking deep breaths
all over again did you know that in 2020
they tweeted the same thing
yeah and i think i flipped out last year
and you know the year before that they
tweeted the same thing
yeah so ever since i made my twitter
account i think in 2013 or something
every single year on waco i've gone into
like long
thread rant crazy person because i've
been obsessed with waco since i was
little
i remember seeing it on the news i think
i was like eight years old
and it was horrifying so break down
what happened for everybody who doesn't
who's not superficial the government
murdered our kids
basically um no what actually happened
was
the branch davidians were living in a
compound in waco texas obviously
and atf and fbi had just flubbed
massively uh a raid on ruby ridge
and they shot a woman who was holding
her 10 month old baby
their 14 year old son while trying to
like stake out and arrest this guy
and so everybody was really pissed off
about it everybody was like
enraged and atf looked bad fbi looked
bad people were really angry at them
so they were like let's get a win let's
go and save these kids from this bad
evil cult and so david crush the leader
of the branch davidians he would
jog into town every day he was close to
local sheriff
the people there um were all
you know easily accessible friendly with
the community
the sheriff loved him they called him
when they were getting raided
but um they wanted to make a big
spectacle about arresting david crush
because he had some illegal gun parts
they sold stuff at gun shows it was you
know
whatever gun control yeah so us
government gun control is really scary
so basically what happened is on
february 28th 1993
they went and they were gonna go serve a
warrant but they wanted it to be flashy
they wanted to have a big blowout
and so they invited the local news to
come well the local news driver
got lost and he asked a usps driver
how to get to the mount caramel which
was the branch davidian compound
and that guy happened to be a branch
davidian so
he warned everybody who was back at the
compound
that something was going wrong and
something was weird was happening
so they all got ready and
they didn't come out and they weren't
going to come out and so
atf breached the top window there's a
very famous video of them going up on a
ladder
and a shootout took place inside so
members of the atf were killed
and they retreated and a standoff ensued
for 51 days
where they were torturing the people
inside
there were i think 27 women 25 children
who died but for 51 days they tortured
these people
they would play sounds of of rabbits
being slaughtered which is a horrific
sound
like really loud through the speakers
they wouldn't give them milk
they turned off the electricity there
were a lot of babies in there
and they couldn't eat so they made a
deal to give them milk but then they put
like recording devices in it
um it was just really bad they we they
did things
there that would be considered war crime
if we did it in another nation
and then ultimately in april it
culminated with
um a cs gas attack they they went and
they told janet reno that
they believed that david crush was
beating babies and raping babies none of
which was true
he had married a 14 year old but that
was legal in texas at the time
i personally disagree with that as most
people would
but it was legal and so
none of this was true they admitted like
five months after the siege that this
wasn't true
but because she they told her that
babies were being like
beaten she was like okay go in with cs
gas
and the fbi
the few sympathetic negotiators were
like
they're not going to have gas masks for
kids and
you know the fbi were like well they'll
have to come out faster then
so on the final day they started
piercing the building with tanks
and shooting cs gas in which
by this point the government knew was
flammable we had seen
the move bombing and several other raids
that ended up
turning buildings into bombs because you
you're putting gas into a building and
breaking it apart
and they didn't have the fire department
there so the building caught fire
there's a debate if
if it was um the atf that started the
fire or if it was the branch chevidians
but either way they did not have the
fire department there to stop it and so
the women and children went and hid in a
half-buried bus
and because the tanks were knocking down
the building
the door to get out got barricaded and
so they shot
tear gas into where the women and
children were and
they died they suffocated the whole
building went up in an
inferno only a few people made it out
it's it's
one of the greatest american tragedies
in my opinion okay
sorry that was really long no no and i'm
sure there's a whole bunch
that was the quick version that was a
few minutes yeah and then every every
year
the atf on twitter commemorates the the
fallen servicemen
over what was probably one of the most
horrific
atrocities and they never say anything
about the women or children or
or men who were killed in there but you
know what the branch davidians do
every year they have a memorial at mount
carmel and they
also remember the atf who died wow along
with their own people
the atf doesn't do that i mean i i i
feel for
the atf the families of these men who
lost their lives sure
but we clearly know who was the wrong on
this one yeah you know i i'm sad when i
hear about war and i hear any
like people and i don't i don't want
anyone to die you know what i mean
it's my issue is that they
only remember the atf people there were
27 children in there
two unborn babies yep and they
killed them whether whether koresh
started the fire or not
which i personally don't believe but you
know that's their theory
even if that's true they were shooting
cs gas into a building did not have the
fire department on standby
knowing that it starts fires and they
could have arrested him any time he
jogged into town
and they didn't because they wanted to
show for the cameras this was
all on them and they they don't even
memorialize the the babies that they
killed it infuriating
they'd have to admit that they killed
these children yeah the other thing too
is even outside of fire
it you you don't fire cs gas into a
closed building because
it displaces oxygen right yeah i was in
turkey
and there was a parking garage it was
during gezi park and they were
very liberally using tear gas as it were
just like
there were so much tear gas on the
ground you were walking and kicking cans
out of the way
and i remember seeing a bunch of the
activists running into a parking a
tunnel
and then when the when the police fired
tear gas into it the next thing we saw
was a bunch of people dragging bodies
out
as soon as they that gas filled the
whole space up there's no air anymore
people were just dropping to the ground
so what what did the atf think was going
to happen if they started firing tear
gas into a closed building
well they claimed that it would make the
women want to protect their children and
run out with their babies
but you know they had been terrorizing
these people for 51 days why would they
trust them to leave the building
yeah if i was them i would have thought
they were going to kill me
so they were and they did yeah yeah yeah
so i was talking to somebody about this
on the anniversary and
they were like well that sounds like it
was handled you know less than
responsibly i was like yeah
and and i was like this is worse than
war because this is the government of
your own country taking you out
i was like i admittedly that was the
first time i had looked into it was the
other day
yesterday on the anniversary and i was
horrified i found pictures i saw like
the you know the fire
ball the charred remains yeah and i i
sent that picture and i was like i mean
look at this
you can tell me what you want the
government bulldozed that whole site
like a week later too
wow they didn't even like go and collect
all the evidence they were like let's
just get rid of this
like quite literally that's crazy yeah
my dad's from waco i get infuriated
yeah my dad's in my family is from waco
so
there's like nothing really related to
that because they all i think they left
well before you know 1993 yeah but
apparently there was you know
a lot of stories of people who knew
people and like how crazy it was
david thibodeau who's one of the people
who who escaped
from the fire he has a book called waco
survivor story
i cannot recommend this book enough it's
what the paramount and netflix
donkey drama was based on partially gary
nosener the fbi negotiator
he also wrote a book and they merged the
two books to make the series
but he's one of the nicest guys i've
ever talked to i've interviewed him and
i just think he is such a
a wonderful person and it breaks my
heart that they killed the woman that
he loved you know it it's all very sad i
i
highly recommend that book or the
paramount series to anyone who wants to
learn more about week
didn't didn't bill barr do something
where he like he got someone off
yeah he defended them saying that they
were doing the right thing
and now i mean i was screaming my head
off when bill maher got put in the admin
i was like no
that kind of makes sense now so so i
have to ask what happened to janet reno
what happened to
anybody was there ever any
accountability well i mean
besides that she's getting uh the same
fiery treatment she gave those kids
that's fair i like that
yeah that makes sense now that that
makes sense but she was never held
accountable no
oh my god of course not cool yeah when
does that stuff ever happen
yeah i i think it's funny as i read more
and more like
gun blogs you know i'm like learning
about you know more about guns living in
the middle of nowhere and also buying
weapons
and it's funny how many comments i see
about the atf and the jokes and the
memes
and the mockery about how like the laws
make no sense
this one's too short but it's also too
long so it can't exist
and then there's i watched a video from
demolition ranch where he talks about
the absurdity of this weapon that's like
a it's a it's a shotgun but it's not a
shotgun so it's technically illegal but
it's not
it's just these people when that when
they're there
it's let me put it this way gun control
makes no sense
when they claim that the same gun in
like different styles
it becomes illegal if it if it's got
like a pistol grip versus a rifle grip
but it's the exact same weapon firing
the exact same thing at the exact same
rate
there's a lot of people who point out
how gun control seems to target
scary weapons as opposed to actually
functional weapons and then you end up
with atf raids going after people for
things that
should not be illegal or quite literally
makes no sense yeah it's hard to know
like it's hard to know if you're
accidentally breaking the law because
the laws are changing all the time
and they're doing well that's one thing
donald trump did luke complains about it
all the time the
bomb stock ban yeah made people
criminals overnight without notice like
i'm sure there were a lot of people who
had no idea what's going on politically
great
and they probably might have a bump
stock sitting in you know in their shed
not realizing it
and they don't know what they bought
maybe they got a bunch of different guns
and stocks and then they passed this law
this guy doesn't watch the news and now
what now he's a felon
and if they go to his house they're
going to find it he's going to go to
prison or get fined or
they could throw tear gas in his house
and kill his kids yeah i mean yeah
depending on
the degree to which this person has
these these items i kind of find it
strange that it's alcohol
tobacco and firearms all together and
explosives like why
alcohol why tobacco what does tobacco
have anything to do with guns
it's weird to me like why would you just
call it the f get rid of the other
make different divisions
yeah something like get tobacco out of
there doesn't it
i understand the contraband running it
in the 20s when did they start the atf
was it like the late 20s
so weird when was tobacco
you have to be honest yeah like they
should get rid of the ats yeah
abolish the 18th abolish if the left
started with abolishing the atf every
conservative would be like yes
we could totally find common ground on
that absolutely definitely let's get rid
of the irs
where where is the left and abolishing
the irs it's like leftist
i know you're all in favor of like
taxation and stuff like that
but it is a government institution can
we agree to get rid of that one yeah or
the fed
yeah we'll start with this and then
we'll work our way up and we'll find
where we hit that wall keep finding
common ground atf goes
you know maybe some of these you know
agencies within dhs maybe we
stop somewhere and then you guys get rid
of a bunch of government institutions we
keep some of them it's a win-win
i want to kind of get rid of homeland
security didn't exist 30 years ago i
don't think it needs to exist now they
just created it after 9 11. no no
it it brought things together so it all
it it took a bunch of different agencies
and put them on put them under one roof
it's like the secret police
they're like the dss of the german reich
no that's
that's totally unnecessary we already
have the national guard we have like the
department of defense we don't need some
new
weird organization that's like
quasi-para military like we should like
the federal government should have it
shouldn't have its own police force
definitely not why not what because it
doesn't
who they who do they adhere to what do
you mean like who do they
who what jurisdiction is going to make
sure they don't get out of line
what federal government what do you mean
like what about any police officer then
who's going to stop any cop from getting
out of line the city the state
and so the feds have those same
jurisdictions the federal police doesn't
like
answer to the state though that's the
problem yes they do well
technically maybe it's jurisdictional
debates so
in washington dc for instance and on
federal jurisdiction you need federal
police
like if a dude shows up with a gun and
starts shooting in dc who's
gonna arrest him i remember how the left
is super pro fbi and feds now
like when i was on the left we hated
snitches
hated the fbi and now all of a sudden
they're like retweeting the fbi
asking for snitches and i'm like
you guys are really chasing homeland
security what's that that's another
department
homeland security is the parent for a
bunch of different divisions
like i think ice is within vhs right fps
yeah yeah
uh um cbp we need customs and border
protection bro
otherwise you get people kidnapping
children
we need federal uh uh um was it federal
police service is what it's called in
washington dc
they have federal police it's a federal
jurisdiction there would like
i'll be honest i don't know a lot of
yeah what's up itunes where trade
centers got knocked down
i i i someone was aggro about what i was
talking about
i was speaking there's an atf guy and
he's calling nsa and he's like
just alone the nsa is another weird one
that didn't used to exist either
definitely creepy yeah
like dhs includes that's what i was
saying some departments
with some some agencies within dhs
because dhs is just
a parent umbrella for a bunch of
organizations i bought attacked when i
was
working on about waco the other day
listen we have triple redundancy on the
internet right now
so for those that are listening online
if you know we're cutting in and out i'm
not entirely sure
we have a triple redundancy on the
internet we have a really robust system
that was built and yeah by this really
smart feller that's right and when one
network goes down it switches
rapidly so we never get kicked off for
us to actually get booted off right now
yeah that's pretty wild conspiracy is
abound no it's not a conspiracy there
there have been a variety of cyber
attacks going on yes they've been having
fun we know that gab got attacked
recently yeah so well how about this
let's read some super chats because we
did go a little bit over
smash the like button if you haven't
already and we're going to rag on cuomo
because he's getting me to
heavily in the members only exclusive
segment coming up
in just about an hour and 20 minutes or
so but uh don't forget to
subscribe hit the like button hit the
like button and the notification bell we
do the show live monday through friday
at 8pm
we are going to timcast.com and now
we're going to read your super chats
we got the first super chat uh youtube
actually cuts off the name of the first
super chat so weird
so annoying because there's like a
little thing like for merchandise i
can't get rid of
oh i see that they said get red-headed
libertarian on here
yes which is cool i love her yes
do it i actually just talked to her
today josie is fantastic i love her
clarence w says just got our pillow in
the mail purchased for glorious
motherland yes
so uh for those that aren't familiar
actually maybe i can i can do this i'll
put the hour pillow up because i'm very
very proud
and i think we might have an
announcement tomorrow on the our pillow
project
now the current hour pillow which is
just
uh it's on teespring and it's just a
design we made where the my in my pillow
is x'ed out and says hour and there's a
revolution fist holding it
a bunch of leftists bought them they
were like dude this slaps this is
awesome
and they're like it's funny it is it's
just a silly funny thing it's not really
making fun of anybody it's just making
it's a pillow just funny
and so leftists were like it's got the
revolution fist heck yeah i like it
and i'm like we're kind of making fun of
the whole thing this sponge
you know it's the communist version of
the my pillow
you know so uh pick up yours today your
our pillow
but uh we actually have the legit
campaign we're doing if you haven't
if you want to get the full details over
at timcast.com we have a segment
explaining the
the the full plan for the our pillow
project
we are going to legit be selling
collectors item box
items they are boxes full of packing
peanuts with burlap sacks in them
and uh you know you can go to mess.com
you'll get the whole whole
explanation for for the members and then
uh there's gonna be some commercials on
fox
news not kidding matthew hammond says i
love cassandra
huh excellent poofy says lids 2024.
oh thanks poop there you go matthew
hammond says tim needs to hire cassandra
for a spooky story cult podcast
gee i wonder where they got that idea
[Laughter]
we might have one next week i tweeted
we're looking for a podcast producer we
may have one
and the idea is to talk a lot about what
what what
what do we say crime culture mysteries
paranormal spooky yes
it's a heart it's hard to describe the
overall theme but it's kind of just like
i don't know how to describe it and i've
already been working on guests
so there's gonna be like it's gonna i'm
really excited for this it'll probably
be once a week
but with like little clips here and
there kind of like how we do this show
just only once a week because it's gonna
be researched produced
and then we're gonna have like a
produced legit breakdown where it's like
vo script sound effects music and then
maybe like an hour or so discussion
about all this crazy stuff but we're
gonna have crazy guess i mean
cassandra's got some crazy
i'm actually surprised that more people
didn't realize what was going on when
you tweeted that
because those are all my favorite topics
yeah like i was like we should get
cassandra involved
we tried doing it before and we weren't
able to make it happen
but now we're going to and then we're
basically going to try and have like
once a week maybe like a two-hour thing
and then throughout the week little
snippets
clips from the show kind of like what
we're doing but uh cassandra's already
pitched me some guests who have said yes
and i'm like wow yeah it's gonna be dark
stuff
this is my uh my favorite my favorite
world of things to talk about and
usually i've always kept it separate
like my facebook i have all my spooky
weird friends and then twitter is all
political
and but i actually know a ton of people
that will be wonderful for a show like
this so
it's going to be fun i'm very excited
yeah the crazy and the [ __ ] in the in
the creepy
eli masora says yolo ladies and gents
hope that's not misgendering
i wanted to know when you're planning
any of the private events that you
talked about
i would love to meet you guys i love
your stuff tell luke f the government to
the moon
so luke is on vacation a lot of people
were like where's luke uh he's on
vacation but luke's a bit of a vagabond
he was legit when he said he was living
in my parking lot he's got like
a mobile home in the parking lot so
maybe he'll come back
maybe he won't i don't know i don't know
but uh you know we're assuming he will
be
people are saying free luke we know
you're keeping him locked up
follow didn't he post on facebook that
his car broke down or something yeah i
think he's stuck in like
south carolina i told him i was like i
can't you can't do it man he's like i
gotta go then
nature calls or you know whatever yeah
apparently and then he gets
he gets in the truck and before he left
we were worried he was going to break
down and but as you know everything's
fine
and then it was like a couple hours
later he's like he can't hold luke down
though he's gonna
luke is gonna luke that's true yeah you
know what this is this is sad right here
dead22 says we need to hear luke's rant
on the atf's waco statement
and luke would have been
he would have been oh that would have
been spicy yeah oh it's too bad luke
oh yeah he's probably listening in his
broken down truck right now
periscope rip luke you're still here in
our hearts
the best political t-shirts that's right
dot com.com
dalman says tim buddy need your help let
people know the minnesota government is
trying to poison the well in pending
trial of derek chauvin
over a million dollar spend on
influencers at this point source
cbsnews.com that's true i saw that i
wanted to go read that article and i
forgot to
have a chance yeah we're getting
internet hiccups this is interesting i
wonder if we're under attack
i wouldn't be surprised it's the atf
it's the aliens
student of history says tim to quote you
if it bleeds it leads
yes they want bloodshed and this
reaction it's purely because these
journalists are sitting there listening
to
addicted by by saving
abel whilst staring staring at trump's
blank twitter page and crying
yes yeah
delhi opulis says please stop saying
australia when you talk about draconian
cover restrictions in melbourne the rest
of the country hasn't had a lockdown
since april last year and
every business has remained open we are
freer than you are
all right delhi in many ways yes
florida is completely open as well we've
had republican states that never
like south dakota never locked down
right i don't know much about it yeah i
don't think so
south africa lockdown so but you are
correct
i'll make sure to say it's a vic it's
victoria isn't it where they've gone
insane
i think north dakota just made a law
that
you can't make masked mandates right i
saw that so there's like a war on which
dakota is a more free dakota right now
that's great paul sam says cassandra is
and always will be one of the coolest
guests you have on your show
she's a badass with some good political
views oh
some spicy ones too i love when they
they pull the clips out of context for
spicy they don't like my jokes nobody
understands me
says tim gals watch your podcast too we
care about smooth plump skin
well i i know i know it's that collagen
get that collagen biotrust thanks
biotrust good for you
click the link in the description below
but um it's like 90 percent dudes who
watch
oh really yeah like 80 actually no no i
think this one is is better
i brought the number of chicks up a
little bit because i've been working
very hard on it
so on my main shows it's like 90 dudes
and this one i think it's like 80 to 85.
like there are women testosterone
probably because there are women on the
show
you know what i mean yeah yeah and
you're a female massive a bunch of dudes
banging the table chanting about how
their gorillas maybe doesn't appeal to
women
it just really appeals to men that's
right all right the scott says canadian
here fyi do we have a constitution and a
charter of rights
the covet hotels do violate both of
those also the whole
hotels are privately owned and entirely
staffed by private security and medical
professionals
freaking weird year about what's going
on up there right this is in canada
yeah i saw what you were tweeting about
that journalist kian bexty
oh yeah i love that so i yeah i did a
segment on him and it's like
it's it's creepy man he wanted food and
he's calling and no one will answer and
he's he's locked down in a hotel for
three days a government quarantine
facility they call it
and when they finally delivered food it
was cold like freezer waffles
and what was next to it was it was
crepes but like dry plain crepes
yeah what are they what are they feeding
these people yeah
and it's like two grand brutal yeah
this is to enter the country you got to
spend two grand and sit up for three
days you're locked down
and if you come into contact with
someone they extend the quarantine oh my
god he said apparently some guys went up
the fire escape and like escaped one of
them was wearing a cowboy hat that's my
favorite detail
crazy all right evil zombie hamster says
i received my i am a gorilla shirt today
i've worn it less than two hours and
it's already covered in my husky's fur
never-ending shedding you know i have to
say we we got a bunch of the samples of
the gorilla shirt finally they're
really good okay so soft yeah i'm
impressed with teespring i gotta get one
we so we have them downstairs awesome
and it's like remarkably soft it's like
really high quality shirts
no joke it's teespring i mean we just
give them the graphics and they print it
so they look awesome
the nick of time says tim isn't brave
enough to read this
tim is a duty head with booty ideas ian
is always right
none of those things are true i'm
absolutely brave enough to read it
because it's funny
it's freaking hilarious dylan keller
says yo cass did you try cyberpunk 2077
i hate it you hate it i hate it i wanted
my money back immediately
i played it for 10 minutes and i still
haven't played it i watched a lot of
gameplay excited because
i love witcher 3. it's the best game
ever i've played it
all the way through probably 10 times
and so i was like really amped
for cyberpunk i i pre-ordered it like a
year in advance or something absurd
um i've never been so disappointed in a
game i don't even like to talk about it
i'm
bitter is it because of the glitches no
it's because the game was horrible
yeah the reason why witcher was so great
is it was beautiful
like you watch it and it's visually
stunning and and the story is so cool
and there's all these little games and
things you can do inside of it
cyberpunk is like hideously
ugly and just i i hate it i hated it
there's no like gwent in it no
no card game sub game or anything no i'm
not going to
i played it for more than 10 minutes i
played it for probably a half an hour
and then i just stopped playing it
impressive i didn't even get to the
glitches i was just like
the first thing i did was okay how do i
switch to third person oh
yeah that's what bothered me i love
playing third person i want to see my
character i want to i i
like switching so like with witcher it's
third person with
uh skyrim it's both right and i like so
it's particularly with skyrim when
you're
traversing i like being third person so
i'm you know running somewhere
and then when i go to combat i like to
switch with cyberpunk it was just like
no
it's forced first person and then i was
kind of like it was basically like grand
theft auto with like a bunch of like
degenerate stuff
i just i love it i hated it i'm really
angry about it actually i wanted my
money back
i think i got a refund because they
manually did it for everybody
oh but the game saw him i don't know
whatever i didn't know i'm gonna wait
like a year
i don't know i got witcher three it's
still in the pipeline i just haven't
played three
because i'm just collecting herbs and
crafting and stuff yeah
kingdom come is great too those are like
my favorite i got that one too
in the pipeline yeah so should we do a
video game podcast apparently that'd be
so fun
i love video games all right even just a
review all right
awesome davey bowie scock says i'm in
seattle
i don't like the the they keep voting
for it they deserve it argument sure
i'll get right on amassing tyrannical
powers to force my neighbors to vote my
way
tim you live in america you elected by
na uh
well for one thing i will say i totally
recognize
that joe biden just blew up a bunch of
syrians and went to war and i complain
about it and i don't like it and i vote
against it
and there's a big difference between joe
biden blowing up
where i live and joe biden blowing up
other places i wouldn't like either of
it
but i will tell you this if i was in a
place say
i don't know the philadelphia suburbs
and black lives matter kept rioting
and there were crazy you know shootouts
i would leave
oh hey i did so look i get it man i'm
not trying to rag on you
i'm just saying i understand there are
people who are trapped there so that
argument isn't about the people who
can't leave because they can't afford it
or otherwise
i'm saying for the people who vote for
it why should i
feel bad for them like the people who
live in these in these areas
that keep voting like 80 democrat i
understand there's a decent amount of
people who don't like it
you know what i'm just going to be harsh
and say you've got to find a way to get
out
when i was in when i lived in chicago i
sold everything at a couple hundred
bucks found a ride share to california
and i had a backpack
and i was homeless i just went i'm like
i don't care and
within a couple days i had a job i had a
place to live and i was i figured it out
maybe not everybody can do it maybe if a
family it's a lot harder but
i would say if you are in portland or
seattle and you don't like what's
happening
you need to sell stuff and then find a
new job
in a different place and get away from
this
life isn't easy only come to west
virginia though if you're extremely red
yeah otherwise you'll hate it no but
they will hate it though
it's crazy like we have confederate
flags everywhere
we play the banjo there's bigfoot don't
do it
there's like ten bigfoot buddies yeah
and they like and they know if you're a
democracy
it's like a snarling wolf bigfoot
and the and the yaogai you know the
yawgwai yeah one from fallout
mothman mothman they'll hang out
together yeah and you'll be like
you'll be in west virginia and they'll
all come see you knife pipes
and then they'll be like liberals come
out
and the monsters will come at you we'll
take the red though
we'll take the red refugees dude to be
honest though
if you were an urban liberal you would
not want to live there because
you have to like actually work you know
we have a couple liberals
in my area but they're like more like
dixiecrats they're not like
they're not woke yeah they're like it's
i don't know who would want to live in a
rural area who was a democrat they they
they come out there and they complain
about everything yeah it's like you
really need to visit with like an airbnb
for a few days
and then consider do you want to deal
like you have to you need a gun you
definitely need to go there's no police
that you know where most places you you
might have a sheriff's office
they can get your house about 40 minutes
so you're going to want to buy guns
and you're going to know how to use them
and your kids are going to need to know
how to use them as well i'm not even
kidding that's true
if you've got if like your kids you know
are in an area and there's a
dangerous criminal and you didn't teach
your kids proper gun safety
you know you're gonna you're gonna
regret it so i don't think any of these
liberals want their kids
learning how to use guns yeah i'd
imagine they would not be happy with
that
leftists on the other hand probably
would be okay with it enough to seem to
like guns
yeah all right nilly boomer says you
can't just have no
luke and not even explain it
well well we explained it later on
everyone everyone in the
in the comments were like where's luke
you got to follow him on instagram
so that you can follow his adventures
yeah he's always been like that i've
known luke for
god for probably over a decade now he's
always been a wonder i used to message
him and be like hey what country are you
in
yeah y'all are lucky he was here as long
as he was yeah yeah yeah because
every day he was like so when are we
leaving and i'm like dude we can't just
when we we got to go on a road trip and
do a tour and i'm like okay we'll do a
tour but we got to like so much
so we we actually are going to do a tour
yeah we're going to do a tour and we're
going to do
live this is a really awesome idea we
had luke and i were talking about how to
do
a teamcast irl on the road with live
events
and so one person asked about when are
we gonna do these live events at the at
you know here on the ground at the
facility
soon it's just cold so now that it's
warming up
we're gonna finish up the venue and then
do limited
sized events you know there's still
cover restrictions but i think we're
allowed to have up to 50 people
so it will be a whole lot of fun and
we'll get you know we'll book people and
we'll do
maybe like we'll do some kind of live
show on a weekend but for the road trip
we've got a couple rvs and we will do
the show the podcast
in the in the rv we'll spend a week in i
think i think we're planning right now
to do nashville
then austin and then um probably
nashville again but i'm not sure maybe a
different city
and that's just because we stop spend a
week there hit texas spend a week in
texas
go back and then we're trying to do it
so that friday nights
we'll actually have the podcast set up
in a venue with like a thousand seats
and people can buy tickets to come and
watch the podcast like this
live on a friday night and the super
chats will just be the audience
questions which will be really really
awesome
that's the plan for now we'll see if we
can make it happen because venues are
like closed
so who knows but that's what we're going
to be doing so there you go
and luke is on vacation because luke's
life is a vacation
and uh i don't know when he'll be back
if he will be back
we'll find out hey you can follow luke
at we are change
on youtube change on instagram and you
can
watch him travel around we got to read a
bunch more mitch dew says i am deep in
wall street bets
game stop still hasn't peaked visit the
uh the squeeze squeeze dot com to
understand the short positions
is the squeeze close the squeeze
squeeze.com is the squeeze quote
oh is the squeeze dot com ah it's a
question i've been checking that
if we hold it will be four thousand two
hundred dollars and sixty nine cents per
share
whoa together strong it's a gorilla
gorilla together strong hold the line
you know when they started posting all
the gorilla memes
i was like this is the perfect
opportunity for the i am a gorilla shirt
i wonder if people would accidentally
buy that thinking it was in some way
related
maybe we need to make a special version
where he's holding money and he's got
sunglasses on and he's wearing
oh we should totally do i didn't want to
co-opt wall street bets though by doing
it yeah because we already had the i am
a gorilla shirt but maybe we can give
them like stacks of cash and do special
edition versions
we do have one we where we're about it's
going to go up soon it's the i'm a girl
love yourself
and he's giving a thumbs up and winking
dude we could do like the gorilla on the
beach sitting in a like a beach chair
with a drink with sunglasses on
we do a whole line so much you can do i
am a gorilla
it's the mascot now i guess james fox
says hey tim a republican living in new
york's 18th district
and i plan on running for congress i'd
love to come on your show
i've reached out on instagram i hope you
reach out soon james fox
um email's probably better but
you know we get inundated with so many
emails and people dm me on instagram and
i was like oh i'll check and i checked
and there's like 10 000 messages i can't
sort through so i just
can't really do anything but uh we we
should we have um
what's a good email maybe info at
timcast yeah spin the ufo is good too if
you
still check that one yeah i took it yeah
okay yeah spin the ufo gmail.com is more
of just like i guess general posts
general stuff
there you go viscid
and the void says i'm here because i
simp over cassandra
they love you on twitter they do thank
you guys
spicy tweets matthew recamp says a few
streams ago someone was asking about
book recommendations i recommend the
author dakota kraut
tim and friends might particularly like
the artorians archive series
think john wick as a philosopher foster
parent in a
medieval setting with magic wow
interesting
the civic nationalist says ian i'm not
white i'm british
british to say i'm white is to compare
me and my culture to the french
german spanish stop applying your ish
american politics to my country thank
you did you did you
no no he was the one who was saying you
know they're all so different
yeah yeah yeah human first irish people
aren't like brits
let's get that cleared we should have
played
maybe we should play the irish guy viral
clip yes
did you see that cassandra no the irish
guy gets stopped at a checkpoint
and he's just yelling at these cops
about the coveted lockdown
and then oh i think i did see that and
they're like do you watch
i don't think it's old oh i mean maybe
like a week or so oh okay maybe longer i
didn't see this but
but the cop is like do you watch the
news sir because he calls it a scam
democrat
and he's like do i watch the news and
then he's like rte it was rte is shite
and then he's like what about the bbc oh
the crown news service
it was just so good old irish guy
listening to too much irish rebel all
right all right jim farm says if you
want to
if you want to unite humanity then it is
christianity we are
christianity we are all equipped in
god's eye we are all rebels sinners
none is righteous not no not one and
there is neither jew nor gentile
neither slave nor free nor is there male
and female
for you are all one christ jesus i
wonder how that jives with the uh the
gender ideology stuff
that quote you're kind of seeing it play
out a little bit on twitter right now
be incredible if we could all live
christian dismiss with religion
and just be unified
yeah he didn't care about religion he
was like a jew that had given it up and
was like
more interested in communication i don't
know i think if you
we should have sheamus on he would he
would be like yes
he knows a lot about catholicism
definitely all right we got one for
cassandra ken w says
for cassandra asian kids grow up
watching anime
which aren't infected with wokeness yet
also for brokerage i highly recommend
opening a roth ira with charles schwab
and invest in their etfs
cool i have been very interested in roth
iras and also
everybody knows i love anime so which
anime
oh i love so many animes i don't know
want to know my favorite yeah of course
are we going to start an anime podcast
my favorite
i'm down my favorite one is steins gate
hands down
love steins gate um i've been watching
neverland uh what's it called the
neverland one
finding never no finding this isn't
finding them no that's like a movie
something like that that one's really
great um it's about these demons who are
farming
chill human children because they have a
pact with the human world
where they're going to stop fighting
with each other but the humans had to
leave some humans behind for them to
breed to eat
wow and so yeah it's great it's on
season two right now i'm a little bit
upset at season two because
emma this character is horrible and it's
ruining the whole thing for me
i can't stand her because she's softy
who doesn't want to kill the demons even
though they ate her family
what i can't deal anyway yeah
anime is great agreed all right
rap zach says atf wants to remember waco
as a texan
we know the story kids were murdered i
have visited the site
wtf makes me sick but what makes me
vomit is that i am not surprised
yeah man for real john mayer says dr
seuss was canceled from virginia school
district
think left think right think low think
high oh the things you can think if only
you try
dr s yeah i was conflicted about that
because i
kind of hate doctor c yeah he's my
favorite he was a war propagandist oh
yeah
oh really is he anti-semitic no he was
jewish
and he accused everybody else of being
anti-static but
very woke uh i actually i love dr seuss
books but i
hated his war propaganda so i remember
that
right touchy stinky ugly says defund the
atf they make laws about things they
don't understand
literally i think leftists would agree
with that they like guns yeah that's
true
i mean as long as you're not talking
about liberals and democrats like the
actual no like like actual leftists
you know there's a lot of things that
like we could agree on
if they weren't that crap
crazy well the problem with leftists is
that they're more likely to ally
themselves with the establishment
democrats yeah
and while there is a problem in my
opinion with establishing republicans
the republicans are just so incredibly
feckless and weak like republican
leadership as an oxymoron
save trump you know mitch mcconnell is
just one of the most spineless
politicians i've ever seen
he like he votes to a quick trump and
then complains about him it's like come
on man look
i'd have infinitely more respect if he
just said i don't like donald trump i'd
be like well
at least he's being honest he's not even
being honest about that i don't know
what the guy likes
he's like scared of he's a turtle he's a
turtle guy and he's scared of everybody
there you go clef the misfit says tim
stop saying the gop can't win without
trump
there's this man you may have heard of
his name is ron desantis
he is a significantly more disciplined
and principled choice for 2024.
i agree a little bit i think you
disagree maybe i really like desantis
um i don't like a bill that he signed
which i view as
anti-free speech which one was that um
he signed a bds law oh
i actually kind of decided with the left
on this because i get some free speech
yeah definitely i think you should be
able to boycott any nation that you
please
i i yeah that's the crazy thing that
really annoys me is like
when i'll speak up like defend an
american's right to speak
and then i'll get these leftists being i
don't hear you standing up for free
speech when the left is censored and i'm
like oh why what happened and they're
like the bds thing i was like okay okay
first of all
i do defend their right to free speech
but more importantly that's not america
okay i'm not i'm not a staunch
nationalist i'm just kind of like
don't be surprised if i see an american
citizen kicked off a platform where
people are talking with the president
and i get upset by it and i'm not super
concerned about israel
and and boycotts but but
just rest assured i care very very much
about middle eastern foreign conflict
israel and stuff and absolutely in
numerous instances i have defended the
right of the left
i actually go to my way to be like is
there something from the left where
they're getting censored on bds because
i want to make sure they they know
i support your free speech i might
disagree with a lot of them on
on all these things disagree with the
alt-right and stuff on their speech but
they're allowed to speak
and then you got to challenge those
ideas
trucker wall says the retaliation to
waco was the okc bombing
i hope we never see something like that
again that's why the government needs to
stop suppressing citizens and stop the
woke of craziness is that true
yeah timothy mcveigh was mad about waco
yeah crazy wow
what was the building that got bomb was
it was a federal building right the
wasn't it the atf building wow the
problem is that there was a daycare on
the first floor
he really should looked into that wow i
mean he really should have not blown up
yeah but like also don't don't blow up
to your home
right next to the daycare that's the
biggest problem i have with a lot of the
with the left and terror in general is
the targeting of
like non-combatants yeah like i'm not i
think
internally in the u.s you violence is
wrong and i think the issue is look at
this like
we're sitting here on a decently high
profile show
talking you know poorly about a
government agency
about the crimes they committed and
there are a large other americans who
know this it is bad for them i just want
to say obviously he shouldn't have
bombed that's not what i said
i didn't mean that that was the only
like that it was good other than the
daycare
i'm just saying like he the daycare
thing that's
really makes it extra bad that was
really upsetting i remember the footage
of
the little little shoes and stuff wow
now this is a really good super chat
bad adam12 says the bureau of alcohol
tobacco and firearms should be a
convenience store not a government
agency yeah
i want a t-shirt yeah i'll get a carton
of
marlboro box 100s that uh let's see what
you got delirium ooh i'll take a couple
of those and i'll take that
556 pistol american america
let's see do we have another one zach
hulk is that an i every time cassandra
is on i learned something new
in this case about waco also she tells
the kinds of jokes i do that no one gets
so i respect her for that as well
well there you go someone understand
somebody gets me yes
i i elite says tim was offended by
gorilla shirt maxing out at 2xl
i am so offended that i lost 42 pounds
in last 24 days
i will be small enough by the end of
march maintaining this expect a
disgruntled image of me later offended
i'm impressed i don't think i was
offended by it
very cool i think i mentioned with ethos
on that a lot of the shirts that we've
sold
are 2xl i wouldn't say the majority it's
not a plurality there's just a lot of
them i noticed
so i think you know we were talking
about it ethan
who famously lost and of weight said
just don't expect it all to happen at
once and just
moderation and you know vigilance i
guess diligence
my thing is you know go for a walk man i
think a lot of people aren't getting
enough vitamin d
especially if you're staying inside too
much playing video games watching movies
especially with the lockdown
if you can get outside and go for a walk
even for like a half an hour
it's amazing the sights you will see
serotonin yeah everything places you'll
go
yes exactly
is that dr seuss
[Laughter]
i was uh i was outside earlier i'm just
so excited for the weather
i can't wait i can't wait until we can
have events and and shows and bands and
everything and just
barbecue man yeah i can't wait to to
grill
we got a bunch of steaks we're going to
grill it's going to be fantastic
we have these events they're not going
to be super big it's going to be like 50
people
but we're going to have drinks soda is
going to be like a big barbecue
gathering i believe we just got a drum
kit right
we have a drum kit coming oh that's
exciting we are going to have bands and
it's going to be
it's going to be it's their private
events but they're going to the tickets
will be publicly available but it's
interesting because it's still
technically private because it's
exclusive to members only
so it'll be really interesting i miss
concerts we'll have uh
we're gonna have bands play in the in
the venue shed thing here
yeah it's gonna be fun coming over all
the time yeah and then when we're like
you know come to the event and you know
special guest cassandra fairbanks will
sell
will sell out instantly yeah from people
coming here to
throw things at me oh but we'll have
security yeah plus we're armed to the
teeth out here so everybody yeah that's
true
and you know gonna get hit with tomatoes
all right let's see
we'll just read a couple more logan orr
says okc bomber was also mad about the
ar band clinton passed
oh yeah an interesting thing timothy
mcveigh
became friends with ted kaczynski in
prison i just saw that recently that's
weird
yeah katie says but cassandra we get
censored from them and get denied our
free speech
do you think we should fight fire with
fire are we talking about the left
i think yeah bds oh well yes and no
i think that censoring or pushing for
censorship in any way
is not good it's not fighting fire with
fire because it's going to get used
against us
um it's like burning your house down
yeah because you're mad that your
neighbor you're hoping your neighbors
will catch on fire too
a lot of a lot of the times i'm like
well let's do to them what they do to us
we have to play by their rules it's a
linsky right
but not in this case not in the case of
censorship i think it's too serious it's
too much of a problem and it's
it's dangerous i i don't think we should
mess with it at all and i will never
support anyone on the left right
anywhere getting censored i just don't
yeah i agree
all right ladies and gentlemen i think
we have to make fun of uh cuomo thank
god
yes and and i'll tell you this they
didn't
cassandra and i were talking about this
and it was kind of like we were talking
and then i stole the idea for the tweet
that they didn't call for cuomo's
resignation when he killed all those
people in nursing homes
it was only after he got me too that
they were like off with his head and
it's like he's 13 000 dead people i mean
that maybe
i guess not so we'll talk about that
over at timcast.com make sure you go and
sign up
that should be up in about an hour or so
it'll probably be a shorter segment but
we'll talk and we'll you know we'll see
how things go
so again timcast.com you can become a
member we got a whole bunch of really
awesome content
members only exclusive full podcast
episodes don't forget you can uh don't
forget to subscribe
smash the like button on this channel
hit the notification bell if you're
listening on
itunes or spotify then leave us a really
good review give us like five stars give
us 10 stars if it lets you i don't know
how many stars you're allowed to give
five and five is that it
all right well give us five and then
tell all your friends because that's the
only real way we grow we don't like run
commercials or anything it's really just
word of mouth if you like the show
share it and it's greatly appreciated
you can follow me on all podca
on all social media platforms at tim
cast my other youtube channels are
youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews
we are back here live monday through
friday at 8pm cassandra did you want to
mention anything before we jump over to
members-only stuff um
i'm on twitter at cassandra rules at
least for now
and then i'm over on parlor gab uh
clubhouse all that other stuff and very
different
and very soon we're gonna have a creepy
cults
crime podcast probably
i don't know when you know we're we're
it's gonna happen and i think it'll be
sundays
but it might be like live monday night
or something
no i think maybe it should it's got to
go up on sunday we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out it's going to be a
produced show it's not going to be a big
newsie show it's going to be more of
like a mystery topics and stuff so it
can be
evergreen but yeah people have been
asking me to do a podcast like that for
years because i'm so obsessed with this
weird stuff
it's going to be oscillated then maybe
we'll just press record and let you talk
for an hour and then stop and we'll do
10 episodes in one day and then we'll be
good
[Laughter]
no i i'm a terrible rambler no scramble
away
hey guys you can follow me also at ian
crossland.net i said something about
jesus earlier i wanted to
want to clarify i don't think that he
hated organized religion
blanketly but that he despised the
corruption and the segregation
brought on by that organization and i
feel the same way about modern societies
so hopefully we can look past
the the confusion and the veil and and
come together as humans like really
you know do this what what i think he
wanted
and and whoever all these other great
prophets thank you tim for this
opportunity
um i love you all and buy a mug on my
website
capitalism ain't so bad if you got if
you do it right that's right
and i'm in the corner pushing buttons
for these guys i'm super excited about
the new potential podcast i'm sour
patchlids on twitter and mines and i'm
real sourpatch lids on
instagram and gab so someone's asking
uh heathen airsoft and jason how do i
get an invite to play airsoft at the
beanie compound
so the way it's working right now
because we don't really have this on the
website we're doing a new website
redesign
everybody who's a 25 member or higher
will get first notification of when
we're doing events
and first access towards buying the
tickets i
don't really like this kind of stuff
because people who are 10 members
are as equally as important to all of us
the issue is
we were trying to figure out the
threshold to where we could make sure
trolls
wouldn't be coming and harassing us and
it felt like you know look we can
provide kind of like a premium access at
25 bucks or more membership
where you'll get a day advance notice
which means
you'll probably not be able to get a
ticket if you're only a 10 member
again i'm not a fan of the classes kind
of stuff of like
access is determined by money but we we
do have to consider
that there are some bad actors who will
try and get access to this house to
figure out where it is to come here and
do bad things
we got to get security cameras and a
bunch of stuff when we start doing this
so i was like
well it's a benefit to those who support
the show and give more
and it's kind of a pay wall to block
troll so
that's how it'll happen and we are going
to have airsoft battles
we were i think luke was talking about
like the daily caller versus the tim
cast irl crew
yeah the riot crew the riot the yeah the
daily caller riot crew versus the tim
cast crew
and uh because we can and things like
that will be happening
i'm not entirely sure what the schedules
will be or how many there will be but i
think we're gonna do a decent amount
because we're really into having these
events once it gets a little bit warmer
so maybe in the next month or so
we're probably gonna start planning this
out in the next couple of weeks so maybe
end of march might be the first event
and uh we'll send out
we'll probably put a post on the website
for people who are members at 25 or
higher
with a portal for getting tickets and
there's probably only going to be like
50 so it'll be pretty tough but you know
i apologize man i'm not a big fan of
lotteries but if there's a high demand
there's only so much we can do
i'll leave it there we're going to go
over to thetimcast.com exclusive segment
to rag on cuomo and we will see you all
there
you